welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another great show for you today
but first uh Lindsay do you have any
media recommendations shoutouts or just
any other happy thoughts to get the Good
Vibes rolling here at the start of the
episode yeah I feel like I always just
have media recommendation cuzz I love
receiving media recommendations so
hopefully people like getting them as
well um but you and I saw the movie
bottoms uh last week I think it's
getting a wider theatrical release and
is available in more theaters now but I
wanted to recommend it because I loved
it so much it's like a teen sex comedy
um it reminded me a lot of Mean Girls
which was like very formative for me in
my teenage years there's also kind of
hints of like the John Hughes movies
from the 80s um but it's set in a high
school it's these two gay girls who
Start a Fight Club to try to make out
with
cheerleaders and it's just a perfect
movie like it's a tight 90 minutes which
I feel like you don't see very often
anymore movies are so long now
and it's very silly and there are parts
of it that are just like absurd without
like explaining why the world is like a
little bit absurd in strange ways that
you're not expecting but it's also
grounded and like I feel like you could
see a lot of your own kind of high
school experience or how the high school
experience is portrayed in this movie um
I really loved it and I think everyone
should see it I hope it becomes like a
classic teen movie yeah I I definitely
enjoy enjoyed it as well and I also need
to give a shout out to Marshon Lynch who
might be the greatest comedic actor of
our times and is just generally I think
one of the funniest people ever yeah so
he plays the teacher who's like The
Faculty adviser for the fight club that
the girls start and I also I heard that
a bunch of his funniest lines were
improvised like he's killing it
absolutely his post NFL career like he's
an acting boy now yeah uh it
also the the plot of the movie I think
was um or at least like parts of it were
slightly like close to home for us in a
bit of a weird like idiosyncratic way
which is that um so like the The Fight
Club ends up happening but one of the
concerns at the start is uh it might get
disbanded because they don't have a
faculty advisor like what if the The
Faculty adviser doesn't show up and uh
that exact thing happened at our high
school yes um like I I I try not to talk
too much about like specific things or
people uh in in the past cuz you know
like I've I've made the choice to be a
somewhat public person but a lot of
other people haven't so like I don't
want to um you know share personal
things that they might not want to be
shared publicly uh but this was on the
news it's already public um we we had a
self-defense Club at our high school um
that lasted about one semester because
the faculty adviser really just didn't
show up uh and so it just turned into an
after school fight club and um this was
right at the time when cell phone
cameras were starting to become
ubiquitous and there was like I'm I'm
not going to give these two people's
name names but like again this was on
the news they're out there but like one
kid just beat the out of another
kid and um it was recorded on a cell
phone video got posted on YouTube yeah
early YouTube and folks were like where
is the faculty adviser he was he was
nowhere to be seen he did not show so he
he got let go um but yeah so that was uh
a a a weird part of my high school
experience that I never expected to
portrayed on the big screen yeah yeah
really nice the movie was a lot blooder
than I was expecting it to be like it
was violent yes but I loved it do you
have a media recommendation today Greg I
do um so we recently watched a
three-part docu series on HBO called
telemarketers which is like kind of an
investigation of this of a particular
kind of scammy tele marketing uh
industry like there there's been a lot
of media about um like foreign
telemarketing scams um like the a lot of
the big like scammy Indian call centers
for instance oh just quick quick
recommendation in there the reply all
longdistance episodes back classic reply
all very good amazing um but yeah so
that that aspect of scammy telemarketing
has gotten a lot of shine um but this
was about a
kind of telemarketer scam that mostly is
is based in the US and uh well this
particular one was based in New Jersey
and it mostly raises money for like kind
of like public sector unions so mostly
police unions but like some some like
firefighter unions and um uh some some
random like scammy Charities related to
like cancer relief funds and stuff like
that um
but yeah so the the person making it was
a guy who just like didn't really have
many life aspirations dropped out of
school young and just a a job at a local
telemarketing Center was the only career
he could get um and yeah he he showed up
and at first he was just like hey this
workplace seems crazy but you know I'm
kind of a burnout so like this is fun I
love it but it is just crazy like the
the folks here are wild um so yeah I'll
I'll just bring my camera in and just
film some of the crazy stuff going on
and then uh he he makes a buddy there
named Patrick J pesus where which the
show is theoretically about
telemarketing it is actually about
Patrick J pesus who is maybe the most
he's one of the most charismatic people
I've ever seen portrayed on screen and I
love him he's incredible um but yeah he
He suggests to the documentarian that
like hey this this is more than just a
wild zany workplace like I think a scam
is going on here so they start
investigating it from the inside and uh
I I won't give any further details to
spoil anything about the documentary or
what they find um but it was it was very
entertaining I I enjoyed it a lot yeah I
really was impressed by how long the
documentary spanned like
the early footage is from 20 years ago
or so yeah I think so like 2002 2003
something like that yeah and by the end
you're in 2020 so it's like a super long
time it's been this guy's like life's
work so far like documenting his
workplace and then investigating and
creating this
documentary of like just this crazy
thing that he experienced when he was a
teenager and it was really incredible
you could tell that so much like love
and thought went into creating this and
it was really special yeah it it was I
we used to have we used to have like a
big documentary phase we haven't watched
a documentary in a while I don't think
but this we used to watch bad
documentaries though yeah yeah but they
I mean a lot of them were very fun like
the The Gerson documentary um where it
starts off kind of normal and then the
last 40 minutes are just like here's how
much coffee to shoot up your butt uh
yeah it took a turn yeah very fun stuff
but anyway this was like an actual very
good entertaining document HBO
documentary yeah good um all right so
you want to you want to get into it yeah
let's get into it okay so before we
start the show we have just two very
quick housekeeping notes um the first is
a bit of an announcement so when the
week where this episode is going to be
released will be the 2-year anniversary
of macro Factor our nutrition app um and
so yeah uh it's been it's been a very
rewarding experience like it's it's
helping a lot of people um and we we
appreciate everyone who's used it who's
checked it out um yeah it's it's
everything related to it uh has just
gone better than we ever could have
anticipated and we are deeply grateful
um um and when this episode is published
um our 2-year annual report will also be
published we can link that in the show
notes so um yeah if you're interested in
just looking back at what we've been
doing for the past year and what we have
planned for this next year um that will
be linked in the show notes if if you
want to check it out like you know if if
maybe you've used it previously and you
left because it didn't have some key
feature you were interested in and
you're like hey does it have this now um
stuff like that will be in the annual
report or if you're a current user and
you're like hey what what do these folks
have planned for the next year um it's a
lot a lot of it's going to be related to
further expanding and improving the
coaching functionality which we're very
excited about uh but yeah if you're
interested in that at all it will be
linked in the show notes second thing
just is more of a general housekeeping
note is uh we're going to be Shifting
the next episode of the podcast after
this one and the next research Spotlight
back by a week um so this episode will
be coming out the 13th of September um
on the prior schedule the next episode
would have been coming out the 27th
instead it will be coming out October
4th uh the reason for that is basically
just we have a lot going on I'm going to
be out of town for a week and so instead
of rushing to just get out lower quality
content just for the sake of getting out
content content uh we're we're just
pushing everything by a week to ensure
that the content is uh of the quality
you've come to expect I'm not going to
say the highest quality that's ever
existed um but people have come to
expect very long very in-depth podcast
episodes yeah that takes time I I feel
like we're not in a position to like
objectively uh quantify the quality of
the podcast no idea you know it it is it
is some level of quality and we don't
want it to go below the normal
so anyway things are getting pushed by a
week uh just so you know when when an
episode doesn't hit your feed two weeks
from now it's not cuz we're taking
another long season break or anything
like that uh another episode will just
be coming out the week after that right
uh all right um plugs really quick and
then get into the content yeah so if
you're enjoying the show please like
rate subscribe and tell your friends it
really helps us if you're interested in
hiring a virtual coach to help you with
your training and or nutrition Stronger
by science has a team of excellent
coaches that can help you you can learn
more at Stronger by science.com
coaching if you want to purchase
supplements from a reliable source and
support the podcast at the same time buy
from bulksupplements.com and use the
code sbsod to get a 5% discount and like
Greg mentioned
and I think we're almost to 990,000
other people using it now which is crazy
and cool uh you can try it for free for
14 days by using the code SPS during
sign up it's available on the App Store
and Google play or if you want to learn
more you can check out the website
[Music]
build more muscle get stronger Etc uh
check out mass that stands for monthly
applications and strength sport um so
yeah if you're a strength or physique
athlete or coach that is an excellent
resource um if you would like to follow
the show uh get plugged into the
communities um Etc join our Facebook
group and or subreddit the Facebook
group is stronger by science Community
the subreddit is reddit.com rstr
Stronger by science um if you would like
to get uh free study breakdowns sent to
your inbox typically every other week on
podcast off weeks though again circling
back to the show notes one of the
research spotlights is going to get
pushed by a week as well just to stick
to that uh research Spotlight podcast
research Spotlight podcast Cadence um
you can uh check that out and sign up at
Stronger by science.com
newsletter uh and finally
as a another reason to join the groups
um if you'd like to ask questions that
we'll answer on the podcast uh you can
record a brief audio clip of those
questions keep it under 60 seconds and
email it to podcast Stronger by
science.com uh when we're recording an
episode on a particular topic and
soliciting questions about that
particular topic we will post about that
in the Facebook group and subreddit so
if you want to uh ask just any general
question you can record that clip send
it to the email address or if you want
to increase the probability that your
questions will get answered when we're
looking for questions on a particular
topic make sure to join the Facebook
group and subreddit so you will know uh
when those prompts come um and I think
that's about it in terms of plugs let's
get into the episode so uh just as a
general note I'm sure I don't know what
this episode's going to be called yet
but I'm sure as you're looking at this
you can see the title and uh it will
either directly state that this is part
two of the micronutrient series we're
working on or the title will strongly
imply that it's part two of the series
um but just want to make it clear we're
we're picking back up where we left off
after the last episode so um yeah check
out the first episode in this series if
you haven't already in this episode what
we'll be discussing is actual
micronutrient targets so uh last last
episode we talked about just the the
general categories of micronutrients
what micronutrients are um but the way
most people interact with micronutrients
is via micronutrient targets like rdas
specifically and almost
exclusively um and so like for instance
I assume most people don't know what the
actual RDA is for say like calcium or
vitamin a or whatever else just right
off the top of their head uh but
nutrition labels tell you how much
calcium or sodium or whatever there is
in a product relative to the RDA like as
a percentage so those nutrient targets
again specifically rdas are really
providing the single Anchor Point that
people have um for interpreting how how
much of each micr nutrient they should
consume um and so yeah like people
generally want to make sure they're
consuming enough micronutrients and
they're they're not uh entering a state
of undernutrition um but most folks also
generally don't have a particularly
nuanced understanding of micronutrient
needs unlike say calories or
macronutrients um so yeah that's that's
what we want to discuss in this episode
kind of where those nutrient targets
come from what they mean and uh how you
can interpret them uh for yourself so um
before we get into all of that before we
we delve into that research and and some
more of those Nuance topics related to
the actual micronutrient targets
themselves um I think we should first
discuss a little bit of the history of
micronutrient targets uh and government
recommendations related to micronutrient
intake and I I believe you did uh quite
a bit of of reading and historical
research on that lens so take it away I
did yeah not as much as ASP ran so don't
be too
scared yeah yeah uh so the first set of
government sponsored recommended dietary
allowances which is rdas was released in
1941 um and I want to talk a little bit
about what prompted that so as American
men were called for military service
during World War II uh a hefty one3 were
found to be suffering from disabilities
known to stem from poor nutrition which
is rough that's that's a lot yeah and
surveys of family eating habits carried
out by government agencies in the mid
30s found that undernourishment was
widespread and
serious so in response to this the
president at the time FDR convened the
national nutrition conference for
defense in 1941 which is just kind of a
wild name for a conference yeah I I mean
I I do think it's um indicative of a lot
of things both both good and bad that um
that are are just kind of Hallmarks of
Modern Life which is like I don't think
I don't think that many people think
that hard about just how many aspects of
our modern world were like directly
shaped by War and like wartime
considerations exactly so yeah like the
the impetus for the first micronutrient
recommendations was was war related um
like you you had data from the 193 30s
suggesting n lots of people are
malnourished but when does the
government decide it's actually time to
take action and do something about it
yeah uh you know when when you want to
make sure that that the that the boys
we're sending over to Europe are are
ready to fight right yeah so the result
of that uh conference was the first set
of government sponsored rdas and it
started with six vitamins and two
minerals so they were vitamins a B1 B2
B3 C and D and calcium and iron um in a
government report called are we well fed
a report on the diets of families in the
US which was also published in 1941 the
authors concluded that only 1/4th of
families in the United States ate a diet
that could be classified as good um and
they they defined good if it exceeded by
50% the minimum requirements set for
those vitamins and minerals M so that's
a relatively low bar but that many
people still failed to clear it exactly
yeah so as an immediate solution the
conference suggested food enrichment
programs that were intended to restore
foods to their pre-processed levels of
nutrients um and food manufacturers had
already started some enrichment
specifically adding B vitamins to flour
in the late 30s when those vitamins
became available in bulk through
industrial synthesis yeah and just as a
little bit of context for that
um a lot of those B vitamins are present
in the germ of wheat but like in general
white flour is is it tastes better it's
easier to work with blah blah blah
whatever um so yeah like like processing
to remove the The Germ of the wheat uh
did make a a tastier product to eat but
did also remove a lot of those vitamins
um so so yeah that that is what is being
added back in in food fortification
programs right yeah it seems like there
are a lot of foods that maybe had more
vitamins and minerals in their
unprocessed form then once um like
industrialization start processing Foods
a lot more it was stripping them of
those vitamins and minerals and so then
this program was basically like okay
let's go add those back in again mhm so
they were adding the B vitamins to flour
um but now everything really went into
speed drive because everyone was really
freaked out about the poor quality of
most Americans diets um the Milling
industry transitioned to enriched flour
and bread products pretty much
voluntarily uh before mandates were even
handed down in
1943 and uh just as a quick aside about
like people generally being freaked out
there also seemed to be a widespread PSA
style warning campaign that was like
freaking people out about vitamin
deficiencies so journalists government
agencies and home economists focused on
General dietary guidelines linking
specific food groups to essential
nutrients so it's not like telling
people like get this vitamin or whatever
it's just telling them like this is the
food you should eat which I I will say
for um for for people who probably
aren't planning on getting super deep
into nutrition science I think that's
probably a good way to go about it um
like if if you tell someone like hey eat
more vitamin K uh then the next question
they'll have is just like hey what foods
are rich in vitamin K exactly so if
you're concerned that people are underc
consuming vitamin K you can say Hey try
to eat some more of these foods that are
rich in vitamin K so that that makes a
lot of sense to me just from a from a
messaging perspective definitely so yeah
it made sense for them to be
recommending food groups but how they
started communicating the importance was
by showing these really disturbing like
before and after photos of vitamin
deprived lab animals so they would show
a deformed underweight really sick
looking vitamin deprived rat as an after
they also used like chicks guinea pigs
and pigeons and jux toos that against
pictures of the wellfed healthy before
rats like before they were deprived of
vitamins which is scary and of course
the information was aimed at women who
are primarily responsible for shopping
planning meals and cooking for their
families so it's like really scaring
people and like communicating like you
better cook a nice meal for your family
or else your kids are going to look like
these sick rats and it's your fault and
it's your fault yeah exactly yeah that I
of like of course that's going to freak
people out but you know there there's
always I think like a a consideration of
like how important messaging is and like
how much you want to freak people out
yeah um cuz yeah if something is like
really crucial like maybe maybe that
serves a productive purpose um but yeah
it sounds like it it sounds like
regardless of the intention behind it
like that that would probably cause
quite a bit of concern I would think so
so the 1940s also came with an expansion
of the recommended food groups in an
attempt to help people get those
vitamins and minerals the new standard
was called the basic seven and I just
wanted to talk about this really quickly
because I just think this is a funny
food group um standard so the seven food
groups one green and yellow vegetables
two oranges tomatoes and grapefruit
three potatoes and other vegetables and
fruit four milk and milk products five
meat poultry fish or eggs six bread
flour and cereals and seven is butter
and fortified margarine hell yeah like
an entire food group for butter that
rocks and also just the classification
of potatoes and other fruits and
vegetables like potatoes being so big
that they get like their own call out
there and then they're just tacking on
and other fruits and vegetables so I
will say potatoes are very good um they
they are uh relative to to the time when
when this was being put out so this was
like what early 1940s right right so
this was kind of during or near the tail
end of the Great Depression mhm and so
in addition to like insufficient
micronutrient consumption there were
also issues related to just just total
calorie intake um cuz this was also
relatively soon after the Dust Bowl uh
as well which which is where a lot of
crops were lost in the in the midwest
because of over farming um and then like
high winds and just kind of a a perfect
storm for for crop failures and so there
were General Food shortages and potatoes
Rock just as a source of of calories in
General Nutrition um I believe potato
I think you can get about four times as
many calories per acre of potatoes than
you can from uh like any other staple
crop like wheat or corn or rice or
whatever um like it's it is a hefty
difference so um and also if memory
serves I think potatoes deplete the soil
less rapidly than other um like staple
crops do probably so yeah and so for the
time period uh recommending increased
potato intake when you're when you're in
an era where a lot of Farmland had just
been lost due to depletion um and there
was just like General widespread
undernutrition um yeah like recommending
people eat potatoes is pretty clutch and
I also think that they're sorry for for
going off on this T this interesting I
love potatoes but so there used to be a
stigma against potatoes like it it was
yeah so it was um I I think a lot of it
had to do with attitudes of like class
perception um because since potatoes
were so cheap and plentiful they were uh
they they were in fact and were also
perceived to be kind of the food of the
underclass and so now I don't think they
have that same kind of stink attached to
them like Everyone likes potatoes
they're delicious uh but it used to be
that a lot of folks would just kind of
avoid potatoes cuz they're like Ah
that's that's poor people food like
that's that's not what you eat if you're
doing better for yourself um so having a
government recommend like hey no like
potatoes are good and we're going to
call them out as like basically their
own food group and yeah like try to eat
some potatoes um it it probably helped
at least a little bit with with some of
those perceptions saying that like hey
potatoes can be a food for everyone you
know it's a PR campaign for
yeah of of all of the things that could
get a PR campaign like I think potatoes
deserve it potatoes Rock that's true so
unfortunately the these seven food
groups lasted for about 20 years by the
1960s though the number of food groups
had been reduced to four much more
boring categories milk vegetables and
fruit meat and Breads and cereal and
just for comparison um I was interested
to see like how this differed from what
the core elements of a healthy diet it
are in the most recent
guidelines and right now it's uh six
categories so one vegetables of all
types two fruits especially whole fruit
three grains at least half of which are
whole grain four Dairy five protein
foods which includes lean meats poultry
and eggs um but also includes like vegan
um protein like beans lentils nuts seeds
and soy products and six is oils
including vegetable oils and oils and
foods that makes
sense so I want to go back to talking
about the rdas and this is going to lead
us into our discussion for today so
those first guidelines in the' 40s only
included the one reference value for the
RDA M and because the allowances Were
Meant to provide Superior nutrition for
military personnel they included a
pretty large margin of safety as well so
even though this guidance was a positive
step forward there were still a lot of
questions about you know consumption of
vitamins and minerals how much you
actually need there was little
information about the lower or upper
bounds so you might know the RDA for
something but you don't know how far
below or above the RDA you can go before
it's actually like dangerous so that
applies both on an individual level and
on a population level for people hoping
to conduct studies to determine rates of
inadequacy and seeing if like things
were improving at all
mhm the rdas were revised every 5 to 10
years after the 40s and in the early 50s
USDA nutritionists created guidelines
for serving sizes for food groups so
knowing how many servings of a food you
need to achieve your RDA was likely very
helpful it's kind of wild that that
wasn't included from the start I'm glad
that they got on that like relatively
quickly well yeah and and it's just a
practical way to address that problem
cuz it's not like yeah it's not like
everyone had like a a smartphone and
mobile app that they could like track
their nutrition on down to the how would
you know you would have no idea yeah so
if you want to eat enough they're just
like hey eat like three cups of right
whatever and like okay like I can I can
wrap my head around that and actually
like quantify it exactly yeah it's
necessary but it was still just the one
number still just the RDA for 50 years
uh I thought I was really surprised by
this the first use of three Dietary
Reference values wasn't until 1991 in
the UK damn so that is like a full 50
years after we got rdas for the first
couple vitamins and minerals um so these
included a lower level the three the
three reference values included a lower
level at which deficiency would be
considered to exist in almost all an
average requirement and a higher level
that would be adequate for almost all in
the age and sex group to which it
pertains mhm from there the dri
framework which is what we're going to
talk about next um in the US was
conceptualized in '94 introduced in '97
and tweaked over the next 10 years or so
and
2011 they revised the dri values for
calcium and vitamin D in 2019 they
revised for sodium and potassium and
just earlier this year they released
revised values for energy but none of
the other dris have been revised since
first published between 97 and 2001 I I
will note that is in the US context uh
in Europe the the efsa is much more
consistently like rolling out updates
and stuff that's good the U like the
drri is what US and Canada use from what
I understand and they they're struggling
there are tons of issues related to
funding and political will methodology
and cooperation between the governments
who are using this framework but this
stuff is really important and there
needs to be a plan for updating it
obvously it's important for formulating
dietary guidance but there are a a lot
of other critical Health applications
that depend on the dris in the US and
Canada um so guiding the design of
health programs used by the VA Federal
hospitals and nursing homes many
civilian Health Facilities as well
guiding the design of healthier Federal
nutrition programs like School meals
Wick and snap uh dris are also used for
dietary Counseling in hospitals long
long-term care facilities and prisons
for ensuring nutrient needs are met for
armed forces which you know was where
this all started yeah call back yeah and
providing a framework that is used by
many other countries and international
organizations when setting their own
standards MH and you know all of these
things are dependent on dris that are
not being updated and it seems like
there's really no plan in place for them
to be able to update them yeah I I think
um I I think in your initial kind of
like longer form notes on this section
you you noted that uh yeah like like you
said there as far as anyone can tell
there's not sort of like wheels turning
or like gears in motion for improving
this which um Ju Just as just as a
general note for for listeners I
mentioned this in the last episode but
um we have some written content on the
macro Factor website about
micronutrients and and all all of that
stuff uh I'll I'll link that again in
the show notes but in I believe the
first article in our micronutrient
series on the website um I link to I I
link to kind of like a postmortem of the
um ah what would you call it like like
collegium or whatever like the group of
people that got together to put together
the first dris um so they they made a
postmortem which was just kind of going
through uh issues they ran into with the
process of generating the dris uh gaps
in the literature and ways that like the
framework could be improved and um
recommendations could be improved in
future iterations and as far as I can
tell like they they they did all of this
work to put together a postmortem to do
a better job next time yeah lay a
foundation and it's now it's been like
20 years and as far as we can tell
there's there's not a next time uh
anywhere on the horizon which which is a
bummer yeah um though I should note as
as mentioned a second ago uh European
health agencies are much more on top of
this the the efsa like is
um is is doing a better job of like
re-evaluating the evidence on a rolling
basis and putting out more updated
reports um I don't think there is still
like as much on going original research
as there was in like the 70s ' 80s 90s
which which was kind of like the Heyday
of like micro nutrient specific research
um but yeah in terms of like rolling
updates to the guidelines uh we we we
kind of kicked it off like we we were
the ones who made the drri framework
which Europe um was heavily inspired by
with their drv framework but they they
are the ones who uh seem to be doing a
much better job of carrying that torque
right well in the UK was the first to
introduce the three values as well yeah
so they've yeah which was influential in
kind of generating the drri framework to
begin with yep um so that out of the way
let's talk about the drri framework and
uh all all of the different
micronutrient kind of targets and values
that we'll be talking about this episode
and what they mean where they come from
y so uh yeah there there are a lot of
acronyms we're going to talk about uh
and I I
apologize about that a little bit but
it's kind of unavoidable like if if
you're digging into research on this
topic you will come across these
acronyms it it's just basic stuff you
have to be aware of most people are
really only aware of rdas and they're
not even that aware of what rdas
actually mean or imply right um so yeah
uh
just as a general note before I dive
into this there are two different sets
of acronyms and I will tell you both of
them but otherwise I'm going to stick to
the American terms just because like
over half of our podcast listeners are
from the US um but also the Frameworks
map one to one onto each other so uh
yeah when for example like when I say
drv or drri just think drv or when I say
RDA just think PR um so yeah it it
should make sense as I get into it yeah
I think so so yeah to start with drri
that stands for Dietary Reference intake
uh and dris refer to just all of the
scientifically derived reference values
for various nutrients in other words uh
drri is the general term used to
describe all of the other nutrient
targets and kind of signposts that I'm
about to discuss um the European version
of drri is drv which stands for Dietary
Reference
value um probably the Anchor Point for
the drri framework which again is is
very rarely discussed um at least to the
public uh is the E which stands for
estimated average requirement uh the the
European version of that is AR which
just stands for average requirement um
and EA RS are are pretty
self-explanatory um name is estimated
average requirement and guess what it is
it is the estimated average requirement
for each particular nutrient um and so
for each nutrient about half of
individuals would need to consume a
little bit more than the E for kind of
Optimal Health and to make sure they're
meeting their nutrient needs and about
half of individuals can probably get
away with consuming a little bit less
than the e um assume uming that the
intake needs for each nutrient are
normally distributed which most of the
time they are um and for what it's worth
I suspect a lot of people think that
rdas are communicating the information
that e are actually communicating y um
in other words I think people broadly
view rdas as like the average
requirement of nutrients um but as I am
literally just about to talk to they are
not the actual average requirement is is
the E so what is the RDA like that's the
big one that most people are aware of uh
or in a European context the PRI which
stands for population reference intake
RDA stands for recommended dietary
allowance um and so yeah like just about
everyone will at least have a passing
familiarity with rdas or at least be
aware of that term um as as mentioned
before standard food labels present
micronutrients in reference to their
rdas and um yeah rather than being the
average requirement for a nutrient you
can you can think of the RDA as kind of
a better safe than sorry micronutrient
Target uh they're designed to meet the
needs of 97 to 98% of the population in
statistical terms uh you you estimate
the needs of uh like the average needs
of
a particular nutrient for the general
population you calculate the variability
uh of those needs like you know some
people will need more some people will
need less calculate that standard
deviation and then the RDA is just two
standard deviations above the mean right
which should cover again like 97 and a
half% that margin of safety that I
talked about because it was developed
for military personnel correct yeah
um all of which is to say it's it's a
good number to shoot
most people are meeting RDA for
particular nutrient there's only two is%
chance that they might need to consume a
little bit more versus um you know there
there will be a very low chance that
they'll wind up with like insufficient
nutrient status um but it is also the
case that most people can probably get
away with consuming less than the RDA
kind of like by definition because it's
a number that's two standard deviations
above the mean uh and and still be
broadly okay the inverse of uh the RDA
or PR and and this is one where
Americans and Europeans agree on an
acronym nice is the LTI or lower
threshold intake and uh yeah so LTI are
basically the inverse of rdas rdas are
two standard deviations above the mean
LTI are two standard deviations below
the mean um and so yeah like about 95%
of individuals will have intake
requirements for each nutrients
somewhere between the LT and the RDA
with the E kind of being the average
midpoint there okay um and so LTI you
can think of as kind of like the bare
minimum you should aim to consume like
there's there will be a pretty good
chance that you will do better if you
consume more than the LTI and also a
very good chance that if you're
consuming less than the LTI for a
particular nutrient um you will probably
wind up with with overall insufficient
intake and probably feel a little better
if you consume a bit more um so that is
that is kind of like the core of the
drri framework you have the e as the
average RDA to standard deviations above
the mean LTI to standard deviations
below yeah so you have like a range
there correct which is really helpful
instead of trying to shoot for an RDA
which is probably more than you need
already and might be discouraging to
shoot for yeah yeah um but then that
begs the question of what do you do with
nutrients where you don't actually have
enough research to determine the average
needs uh or certainly don't have enough
research to calculate the V the the
interindividual variability in terms of
needs for that nutrient yeah uh and for
that you have the AI which again this is
a shared acronym between the US and
Europe that stands for adequate intake
um and AIS
are kind of similar to rdas or pris or
sometimes e ARS or ar ARS uh kind of
depending on as I'm about to talk about
they're they're kind of a mess sometimes
and don't always communicate the exact
same thing uh but they're there's
supposed to function like kind of
similarly to rdas most of the time uh
but they are kind of a bit less
scientifically rigorous so essentially
to calculate in E and then by extension
um uh in RDA or an LTI you need a
certain amount and quality of evidence
to actually be able to calculate and
quantify those things um so if a
nutrient only has an AI what that means
is that they are confident that it is an
essential nutrient and you need to
consume some amount of it for good
health right but the research is
insufficient to actually
like understand and describe the the
spectrum of needs for that nutrient um
so
AIS sometimes communicate slightly
different things the way that they're
typically set is researchers will study
the dietary patterns of people who are
apparently healthy and who aren't
experiencing the negative effects that
you would experience if you were
consuming in ad in an inadequate amount
of that nutrient um and then you just
look at the average intake of that
nutrient in that population and you say
Well it appears to be adequate that is
the adequate intake like that that might
sound too simplistic but that is how
most AIS are set right um but there are
sometimes other ways that they could be
set so sometimes ARS are set based on
the lowest observe intake at which no
signs of insufficiency are observed in a
population so it would be kind of like
the a similar setup to what I was
talking about before you take an
apparently healthy population um you
look at the intake of that nutrient in
the population but instead of looking at
the average uh intake in that apparently
healthy population you kind of look at
like how low the lowest intake is in
that apparently healthy population and
say well the these people are consuming
this amount they seem to be fine so that
is probably an adequate amount um and
sometimes it's defined in reference to
some other external standard um so that
is the case for instance uh for calcium
intake targets for infants um that is an
AI instead of like a e RDA LTI type of
deal okay um in in part just because
like there's kind of there's kind of a a
moral imperative of like if you think
that a baby is malnourished like instead
of taking a second to observe them and
yeah and try to understand it's just
like no like important to just give them
calcium like this is this is critical we
need to get on this pretty quick um it's
like the the AI for calcium intake for
babies is uh defined in reference to the
calcium intake they would receive if
they were exclusively fed breast milk um
so like that's how kind of how much for
how much calcium is put in infant
formula is determined makes sense it's
like well they're like nature figured it
out so we'll just do that yeah yeah like
like breastfed babies seem to be fine
like they seem we we assume they're
getting enough calcium we certainly hope
so so that seems to be an adequate
amount so yeah that's that's how the AI
is defined there um so yeah in other
words like the exact like information
that is like implied and communicated by
an AI differs from nutrient to nutrient
to some extent uh but the functional
takeaway is the same um you have an AI
because there's not enough research to
Define an e and RDA um but if you
consume the AI like there's a very good
chance that you will be consuming enough
of that particular nutrient which is why
I said like functionally you can think
of them as pretty similar to the RDA cuz
that's broadly what RDA a are are
communicating as well uh and then the
final acronym to talk about is the UL
which is also a shared acronym between
both the American and European
Frameworks and UL stands for tolerable
upper intake level um and so not every
nutrient has a UL for some nutrients
there are no known drawbacks of
consuming a lot of that particular
nutrient so
uh for instance a lot of the B vitamins
fall into this category it's like uh I
don't want to throw out any specific on
I I don't want to it up like like I
know that there's a UL for vitamin B6
for instance as I discussed in the last
episode but like I think that like
thamin for instance I think if you just
consume a lot of it your body just
excretes the excess so kind of like who
cares we don't need this um yeah and I I
I hope that's the case for vitamin B12 I
assume it is cuz like some people like
like megga do the out of vitamin
B12 and seem broadly fine so so yeah
like not every vitamin or mineral has a
UL but but alive do um
and essentially what it is communicating
is the amount that you can consume on an
ongoing basis and have very low risk of
negative effects related to overc
consumption um and there's a bit of a
margin of safety built into the UL as
well depending on the severity of um the
severity of the consequence of consuming
too much that makes sense uh and also a
margin of safety built in based on like
the quality of the research supporting
the UL okay um so yeah just for instance
um like vitamin C mhm if you consume too
much vitamin C you just kind of get an
ouchy tummy like maybe you get some
nausea maybe you get a little diarrhea
but like it's water soluble like you'll
you'll poop for a day or two and then
broadly be fine like it's it's not going
to cause any lasting damage um but
excess vitamin A intake can be lethal um
like you you consume too much and you
die or if you don't consume enough to
die it could cause like pretty severe
liver damage
um and so
yeah
the the degree of safety is is
determined in part by kind of the
severity of those consequences and and
like I said also the the level of
evidence supporting them so there are
two other um just just broad Concepts to
be aware of here one is the no adverse
effect level uh for a particular
nutrient which is often determined by
like case studies where um yeah like
like what what is the largest amount of
a nutrient that we see people regularly
consuming and just never having issues
with it or if you don't have like a a
rigorously Quantified no adverse effect
level you might have a lowest observed
adverse effect level which is like
almost always kind of defined by case
studies or sometimes animal research
which is then extrapolated
and uh so that's that's essentially just
like what is what is the least amount of
a nutrient that we see uh someone at
some point consuming and having an
adverse event that we are very confident
we can trace back to overc consumption
of the nutrient versus something else um
and yeah
so like the amount of evidence like
supporting a no adverse effect level or
a lowest observed adverse effect level
um and also like where that evidence is
coming from is it based on a larger
population study is it coming from just
like a handful of little case studies or
is it extrapolated from animal research
all of those things will determine how
much of a margin of safety is built into
the UL so like for instance with vitamin
C I think the UL is kind of like kind of
right below the lowest adverse effect
level where it's like if if you and I
think it's if memory serves it's 2,000
milligrams maybe 1,000 milligrams
whatever don't take that to the bank U
but yeah it's it's somewhere around
there and it's just like yeah if you
consume a little more than that like if
if you do have have the absolute tarity
to over consume vitamin C we don't need
to build in that much of a margin of
safety cuz like you're not going to be
fine yeah you're not going to be that
negatively affected by it um versus
something like vitamin A
Marin of safety built in where um like
the the UL for vitamin A is 3,000
micrograms per day which is like really
high for most diets but is also like
kind of low if you consume a decent
amount of liver so like a single serving
of
uh like raw beef liver um which I assume
you'll cook first but like a 100 gram
serving of raw beef liver depends um
yeah who knows I mean you probably there
there's a whole King there's a whole
King about eating raw liver I I guess so
uh but yeah like a 100 grams of raw beef
liver contains like 5,000 micrograms of
vitamin A which is notably above the UL
um but the UL is
communicating like the amount that you
could
consume uh for for an extended period of
time even if you're at a high risk of
like deleterious effects of overc
consumption
while like very very likely being safe
yes and so for instance like most people
could probably have like a serving of
liver a day and be fine because there's
a large margin of safety built into that
UL yeah they don't want people bumping
up against that top right number yeah um
and and like I said there is like a
chronic consumption
uh aspect of this so like if you wanted
to kill yourself by consuming like an
acute toxic dose of vitamin A that
generally requires like close to 100,000
micrograms like somewhere between like
70 and 100,000 micrograms which is way
higher than the 3,000 microgram UL um
and chronic toxicity also is generally
observed when people are eating around
10 times the RDA per day so like 7,000
to 9,000 micrograms per day so like the
the UL for vitamin A is like around
one third of the amount that people
typically are consuming if they have
chronic toxicity and like one 30th of
the amount that people would typically
need to consume for acute toxicity but
you know like vitamin A toxicity has
such severe consequences they do build
in a pretty large margin of safety there
um so yeah like like uls do communicate
slightly different things for different
nutrients but but by and large it's
saying like hey if you if you consume
less than this per day even if you're at
high risk of negative effects of overc
consumption there's a very very good
chance you'll be fine right but by
extension um if you like slightly
consume like go over the UL for a
particular nutrient one day you don't
need to call Poison Control like you'll
you'll probably be fine yeah so yeah
just just treat it as kind of a soft
limit where if you absolutely blow the
past it maybe you need to be a
little concerned if you just kind of
exceed it a little bit from time to time
like it's probably okay but try not to
do that like that's that is Broad how I
would interpret a
UL
um so yeah uh let's see so kind of like
circling back um just just to kind of
recap this discussion of all of these
acronyms um nutrition labels what what
they report and like exclusively what
they report is um nutrient content of a
food relative to the RDA and rdas are
the values that are drilled into our
heads um and that that does make sense
from a public health perspective like
you it it might lead to some unnecessary
degree of concern because like By
definition most people don't need to
consume all the way up to the RDA and so
it might it might make some people like
a little bit neurotic uh where it's like
oh no like I'm a little under my rdas
like is is that going to cause nutrient
deficiencies or whatever um but it's
also the case that like most people
don't need to know this entire framework
but I think that the way that that these
dris are often communicated does does
lend itself to to an unnuanced
understanding of this stuff where where
a lot of people uh might think that like
oh if I am below the rdas I am therefore
deficient in that nutrient which is like
very very often not the case uh or
conversely like if I go over the RDA
like oh no I'm over consuming it like
that's also bad which also is typically
not the case like there there for most
nutrients there is like a very large gap
between the RDA and the UL um so yeah
like I I just wanted to communicate all
of that stuff like this this may feel a
little bit Overkill to go through what
all of these dris mean but I think it is
useful just just to understand a
typically how how little is communicated
to us about micronutrient needs and two
like just so you'll have a a stronger
like mental framework for understanding
the span of of nutrient needs um kind of
both on an individual and population
level and how to think about each one of
those
dris okay Greg now that you've discussed
what the dris are communicating will you
talk a little bit about the process for
determining these targets yeah yeah
absolutely so um as I was writing the
website content for
[Music]
kind of like the drri framework and and
targets for a particular nutrient and
the first step is determining the
appropriate analytical endpoint to
analyze in the first place so that could
be a different analytical endpoint for
different nutrients so it could be for
instance the balance of a nutrient
within your body so the the example I'm
about to provide I'm going to talk about
calcium and so like the dris for calcium
are based on calcium balance studies so
okay um how much calcium is excreted
relative to consumption at different
levels of calcium intake like that is is
one way that uh it might be determined
um another way might be blood biomarkers
so for instance if you know that a a
particular circulating level of a
particular nutrient in your blood is
what is either causitive of or like
associated with the health outcome
you're interested in you might look at
those those blood biomarkers either of
nutrients or just like something else
that is influenced by the nutrient um or
it might just be symptomology so you
look at how much of a particular
nutrient people need to consume to not
exhibit the symptoms that result from
under consumption of that nutrient those
are those are kind of most of the broad
categories of analytical endpoints that
folks would look at to kind of start
determining uh e rdas ltis um but yeah
that's the first step just determine
that analytical endpoint the second step
is to analyze the data so the folks who
come up with these targets by and large
are kind of doing a systematic review uh
a Andor meta analysis of research that
has already been published um usually
they are not going and doing original
research for themselves to determine
this stuff um so yeah like typically um
this is going to start with a
metaanalysis of studies that are
directly relevant to the selected
analytical endpoint um so it might be
the results of multiple depletion
repletion studies which I believe I
mentioned in the last episode and I'll
talk about a little bit more later um or
it might be the results of multiple
nutrient balance studies for instance um
and I'll I'll use calcium as an example
here so um the the rdas and LTI and E
for calcium are determined by calcium
balance studies um instead of kind of
like looking at like population levels
of calcium intake relative to say
osteoporosis risk which could be
confounded by any number of things or
just kind of give you a bad snapshot
like if if you look at people's calcium
consumption say every 5 years and then
osteoporosis risk late in life like who
knows how their intake changed over time
or who knows if like the survey data was
like actually representative of their
intake at the time like there there's a
lot of kind of analytical challenges
there whereas ultimately what you're
interested in with calcium for the most
part is just calcium balance like how
how much calcium are people actually
retaining that gives you a really good
indication of you know are they are they
preserving bone are they gaining bone
are they losing bone and that's mostly
what you're interested in with calcium
um so yeah the way calcium balance
studies work is they just analyze
calcium intake versus excretion
monitoring intake is simple enough you
just monitor the food and beverages
people consume you know the calcium
content of those foods and beverages
bada bing bada boom you know intake
monitoring excretion is also
straightforward although it's a little
bit gross so you consume calcium your
body absorbs a lot of it doesn't absorb
all of it y um and some of it passes
through your digestive tract and you
poop it out uh and then once it's
absorbed um you know maybe some of it
isn't directly utilized in bone
formation or maybe some bone breakdown
just bone turnover is taking place you
have excess calcium that needs to be
excreted you do that in your urine so
you monitor food intake you collect poop
you collect urine you look how much
calcium is going in and you look at how
much calcium is going out and from that
you can determine are people in net
positive calcium balance or net negative
calcium balance um and so yeah for for
determining the E and by extension RDA
and LTI for calcium um you look at all
of the studies that have analyzed
calcium balance and then you're
essentially just kind of looking for the
point at which calcium balance is on
average neutral and that would be your e
and then you calculate the variability
of calcium needs in order to attain uh
neutral calcium balance and so two
standard deviations above that you would
put the RDA two standard deviations
below that or uh below the E you would
put the
LTI and uh that's about it like that's
that is that first step to kind of build
in that margin of safety um and I will
just note that for a lot of nutrients
maybe most nutrients um the results can
vary quite a bit study to study like
often times the data is somewhat murky
and and you might be able to find like
an individual study with like hundreds
of individuals that would that would
support a much lower RDA or uh again
like large well-powered studies um that
would support like a much higher RDA and
it's not always clear why you're seeing
different results in those studies um so
like it is sometimes a little bit murky
and I'll I'll link this in the show
notes as well um like you I I used this
calcium illustration in one of the
website articles uh as well and there is
like a graph that's kind of like the
output of this of this meta analysis on
calcium balance studies which was then
used to determine uh like in in this
case the the like PRI and AR cuz like
this was a efsa publication
[Music]
like yeah ju just check it out for
yourself and like imagine that like the
trend lines and like error lines weren't
present and it just looks like it's all
over the place well yeah like like check
it out and try to determine for yourself
like if if you would be like extremely
confident at at what those figures
should be and I suspect that will not be
the case that seems so stressful trying
to determine a value or a set of values
based on that yeah I I mean like I I
will say I think based on what e or well
ARs and pris and whatever are supposed
to communicate I think they did like
absolutely the best job they could with
the data that existed but it's just like
the data that exists like like sometimes
you look at a data set and like what it
is telling you is just crystal
clear
often times with these nutrient targets
it it's not like it is a little bit
murky yeah and I guess that makes sense
but like we talked about last episode
when you see those exact figures you're
like oh it must have been extremely
obvious like why they set these figures
as it is or as they are like the data
must be extremely clear on this yeah and
nope no I I would not say that it is um
and and calcium is an example of a
nutrient that there is like quite a bit
of research on um oh yeah so because it
was it was one of the ogs that like f
was worried about there H there has been
a lot osteoporosis has been a public
health concern for a long time there is
a lot of research on calcium right um so
yeah it's it's there there are like kind
of some judgment calls to make with
calcium there are even more judgment
calls to make with nutrients that just
have less research on them that makes
sense um so yeah that that's step two
you you kind of collect and analyze the
data that's been published um and then
step three you kind of have like final
adjustments and rounding um so like for
instance with calcium balance studies
there is like a little adjustment that
needs to be made to kind of the the
results of that meta analysisc because
those calcium balance studies monitor
intake but they only monitor excretion
from urine and feces but you also lose a
little bit of calcium in your sweat
which so complicated yeah and also like
researchers aren't going to collect
every drop of sweat from 100 individuals
for few weeks um well yeah I mean like
you they can but they're not going to
you can do it for like a couple hours
like you you can't do that for days or
weeks at a time and if you did it might
give you unrepresentative data because
like those suits will probably make you
sweat more so it might give you an
unrealistic understanding of how much
calcium is lost in sweat
um oh my gosh yeah so anyways like that
that is just like data that is
unaccounted for in the studies that are
used to determine this stuff um but we
do know that in general folks lose about
40 milligrams of calcium per day in
their sweat so they just kind of like
looked at the data and they said hey
we're just going to bump all of these
numbers up by 40 because folks are
losing about 40 more milligrams of
calcium than what these studies are
actually accounting for uh and then
like I said it's final adjustments and
rounding um so it's rounding cuz humans
like nice round numbers and once you add
all of the adjustments like the the AR
for calcium would have been
745 milligrams per day the RDA would
have been
944 uh people don't like that so it's
just like hey PRI it's 950 uh AR 750 so
yeah that's kind of the final process
just just to wind up with numbers that
humans like rather than numbers that
aren't functionally different that that
people won't like yeah
um and so yeah like I think that um and
I also think that like Calum does
provide a pretty good illustration of
how large the range of individual
nutrient needs can be okay so like in in
the US for instance I think the RDA for
calcium's like 1,000 milligrams per day
the the pr um for calcium like in Europe
is is 950 Mig per day and that is the
number that is communicated to people
but the AR was 750 which is a little bit
lower and the LTI was like 550 so the
total range from like the LTI to the RDA
is like a 400 milligram per day range
and the r the the PRI is is like not
quite 2x that LTI but like it's
relatively close like there there is a
big difference between 550 and 950 um
and like when you when you look at the
individual data that went into
supporting that range like there were
folks who were in positive calcium
balance consuming like 5 600 milligram
of calcium per day and there were also a
handful of people who were in negative
calcium balance consuming like 1,100
milligrams per day so like there is a a
pretty big range there
and um I I think people do find that a
little bit surprising like does does
that surprise you at all or or like did
it surprise you when you encountered
this for the first time yeah definitely
I wonder I mean is it something that
you're aware of as an individual like is
it usually linked to some sort of
illness or
um something that you would be aware of
if you went to a doctor or got blood
work done or something or is it just
kind of like yeah some people just have
different needs and we're not really
sure why oh man it would it would depend
like person to person nutrient to
nutrient um cuz yeah like
the the impacts of
like well you know I think the impacts
of like insufficient consumption like
not deficient but like a little bit less
than would be optimal I think that
they're like rarely obvious and like
probably wouldn't show up with blood
work most of the time
um and like in in the case of calcium
like if you're not getting like a full
blood panel done or like getting a dexa
scan every year to look and see how like
bone mineral density is changing um you
you probably like you might never find
out so it's not like you're experiencing
some sort of symptom that would make you
think like I think I need more calcium
yeah probably not um and the thing the
thing is like
the like there there are a lot of people
who can probably consume a little bit
less of a nutrient than what their body
theoretically needs for like their
entire life and generally be fine um so
this this is this is something that I
was planning on talking a little bit
more about in episode three okay which
is that like there is there is like a
pretty Stark difference between um like
insufficient intake and deficient intake
of a particular nutrient and like
deficiencies are almost impossible to
not notice cuz like they cause severe
problems um and so like in in the case
of like if you have def deficient
calcium intake that causes like pretty
significant feelings of lethargy um like
pretty extreme like muscular fatigue and
weakness um oh man like I said I was
planning on talking about this next
episode so I don't I don't have
everything episode no no it's it's fine
like I'll I'll do a decent enough job
here um and and it can also just cause
like heart attacks like heart failure um
because like calcium is important for
like regulating heart rhythm um so yeah
like if if it kind of comes on gradually
it may not be like immediately obvious
that like hey I'm experiencing these
things because I'm not consuming enough
calcium or like I suddenly stopped
consuming enough calcium but there will
be things that are like significantly
wrong that would suggest you like hey I
should probably get this checked out um
and that that is typically the case for
like deficient nutrient
intake insufficient nutrient intake is
usually like you you probably wouldn't
even notice and often the deleterious
effects aren't even like guaranteed to
happen to you in the first place
um and so like for instance I just
talked about what would happen if you
had like truly deficient calcium intake
kind of the worst impact of insufficient
calcium intake a a little bit less than
your body needs like kind of chronically
putting you a negative calcium balance
is you have an elevated like you'll wind
up with an elevated risk of osteoporosis
which is like it's not something you
want you know like but that's
also a not something you're going to
realize until you get like quite a bit
older like it's it's not going to show
up until like considerably down the line
unless again like you're monitoring your
bone mineral density every year and
seeing like consistent decreases even in
your 20s or 30s or or whatnot and also
like the extent to which it increases
your risk is fairly modest like um
insufficient calcium intake I believe is
associated with like a 10% increase in
OST in osteoporosis risk which like
isn't nothing and like I think more
people than folks realize do get
osteoporosis at some point in their
lifetime so it's it's not something
where it's like oh it's a 10% risk going
up from like 3% to 3.3% like it is it is
like in real terms a pretty large
increase in risk as well but you know it
it is something where like until that
happens you you probably wouldn't have
any like external um like obvious signs
that you're not consuming quite enough
and again it is like an a 10% increase
in it's not like a guarantee like there
there will be a fair amount of people
who like may have wound up with really
high bone mineral density and then they
for the rest of their life are in like
slightly insufficient calcium
consumption range and just never have a
problem yeah yeah um so yeah yeah it is
surprising I it makes sense like you
said when you think about it
because you know individual needs
are present for a lot of different
things but I feel like with food and
even more with vitamins and minerals it
does feel like we kind of think of our
bodies as machines and it's like
everybody needs the same amount you just
put that in and then you're fine yeah um
but yeah just got to change the oil
right but it's different for everybody
mhm and and I do think I do think that
is kind of intuitive once you kind of
like sit down and think about it a
little bit more cuz like you know the
the like nutrient labels might label
total calor needs in reference to a
2,000 calorie standard MH but once
people start getting a little bit
interested in nutrition they realize
like oh wait no like energy needs differ
between individuals if like you're small
sedentary like maybe you only need to
consume 1,500 calories a day if you're
like large and like super highly active
like maybe it's four or 5,000 calories a
day like there's an acknowledgement that
there are pretty big ranges there um and
so like I I I don't want to get too far
out over my skis I just want to State on
the on the front end that like I kind of
assume that this is the case but I'm not
like positive that it is in terms of
calcium needs like I kind of assume that
it probably just relates to like how
large your bones are you know like if
you're a big person with a big frame and
a lot of like a shitload of Cal in your
bones like I assume you probably need to
eat more calcium to maintain a positive
calcium balance um and I I'll also note
like as I mentioned before like the the
research on some of this stuff is like
kind of murky like there's there is an
acknowledgement that needs for these
nutrients differ between individuals but
there's a little bit less research on
why that is the case and I
suspect
I suspect a lot of it probably does just
generally have to do with body size um
you know I I kind of think that like
smaller people who just they they have
less stuff and like they there's there's
less stuff in them you know um less
stuff in the beat Sack or I mean like
for a more kind of like concrete example
a lot of the B vitamins are like
co-enzymes related to steps in the
process of energy metabolism yeah and
like if you're just doing less energy
metabolism because you're burning less
energy per day I kind of assume you
that's that might be a factor
contributing to you your B vitamin needs
being like below the e instead of above
right um yeah there there's there's just
less research on that and I I kind of
think if there was more and better
research you could probably have kind of
like more granular and appropriate
individual recommendations instead
instead of just kind of like pointing
everyone at the same kind of broad range
yeah um and a range is even like more
information that a lot of people get
like like we've talked about most people
really only think of it in terms of an
RDA yeah so thinking of it in terms of a
range even if it's like a population
level range is still like a step up and
still helps you understand it a little
bit better than just thinking about it
in terms of this one value yeah for
sure um all right so kind of the the key
points here are that I I think that like
recommendation like micronutrient
recommendations I are quite a bit less
precise than I think a lot of people
realize
um for for a couple reasons like the
data is rarely super cut and dry um
again like I I'll I'll refer you to the
graph of kind of like how the calcium
targets were determined um um like I and
I'm not trying to say that like this is
all and people are doing a bad
job it's just that like it's there there
is yeah like it there is just more
interindividual variability and more
just bro General murkiness in the data
that exists than than I suspect people
assume yeah um also there are sometimes
even disagreements about what analytical
endpoints to focus on in the first place
um so like I mentioned with calcium they
ended up going with calcium balance
studies but like a credible case could
be made
for um like research like like more so
focusing on Research looking at calcium
intake over a lifespan and like its
relationship with osteoporosis risk okay
like they decided against that for
several reasons but like a a credible
case could be made like maybe that's
that that is an inpoint you could look
at instead and that's step one of the
process is determining that analytical
endpoint so then everything that flows
down from there is based on this one
thing that could have been different and
what result would we have gotten if we
had looked at a different endpoint yeah
yeah and also like I I am absolutely not
implying they looked at the wrong
analytical end point there like based on
what I know I suspect calcium balance
studies were the way to go and also like
I'm I'm not an expert on that so like I
assume they made a better choice than I
would but like I think it's just
important to say like there are judgment
calls here there are judgment calls that
have to be made and there are people who
are experts who don't always agree about
the Judgment calls that are made um next
thing is that there are like potential
drawbacks just regarding the the general
types of research that are used to
generate dris um so as I mentioned
sometimes they're based on like blood
biomarkers but it is not always
exclusively the nutrient you're
consuming itself that would influence
blood biomarkers for that nutrient so an
example here is vitamin D um blood
vitamin D levels are certainly
influenced by vitamin D intake but
they're also influenced by like how much
time you spend outside what latitude you
live at and the melanin content of your
skin like how much just skin vitamin D
you're synthesizing um and then like
other nutritional factors influence
balance of particular nutrients so like
with calcium they're looking at calcium
balance studies but vitamin D intake um
or like vitamin D levels influence
calcium absorption and vitamin K levels
or vitamin K intake influence calcium
deposition into bones which influences
calcium balance so like a lot of times
the research is looking at a single
variable like calcium intake versus
calcium excretion when there are other
nutritional factors even just like other
micronutrients that could be influencing
that um which you know then makes it
like yeah just like adds noise to kind
of that single variable analysis of
calcium intake versus
excretion um and the last thing is is
that for the nutrients where the an the
analytical endpoint selected is like in
is based on like acute findings it's not
always completely obvious um that acute
findings would necessarily and
inherently generalize to long-term
outcomes so um this has been like a
criticism and just
like criticism SL like discussion topic
uh for for decades um in like amongst
the people who do this type of research
it's like a lot of the a lot of the the
micronutrient uh um like dris are based
on depletion repletion studies and uh so
like I said I'll I I said I would talk
about that a little bit more and the way
that they tend to work
is um like like sometimes with humans
sometimes with with lab animals you just
like feed them a controlled diet that
has none of a particular nutrient um for
a while and like bad things start
cropping up and then you just kind of
like titrate the dose back up or or you
might have like multiple groups where
it's just like hey this group we're
going to give you like a quarter of what
we think you need this group we're going
to give you half this group we're going
to give you 3/4 whatever um so like it
starts with with the depletion stage and
then with the repletion what you're what
you're looking at is kind of the average
um amount of intake you need during that
repletion stage to Amel ameliorate the
problems that were caused by the
depletion yes um and then the LTI is
kind of like hey where do we start
seeing improvements being made RDA is
kind of like at what point is everyone
fine and we've like fully rectified the
issue and so like those are relatively
acute studies um like they they take
place over a period of weeks or months
but you know you're eating food over a
period of years like your whole life um
and so it's not necessarily inherently
obvious that the way your body would
respond to acute complete uh depletion
like like zero consumption of a nutrient
and then it being reintroduced there's
there's no guarantee that your body
would respond to that the exact same way
as it would to just consuming a little
bit less or a little bit more of a
nutrient kind of forever right um cuz
yeah like there there might be kind of
compensatory mechanisms that would kick
in if like you consumed say a little bit
less vitamin A all the time like like I
don't like I'm not saying that that is
the case I don't know what those
compensatory mechanisms would be but it
it very well could be the case that like
hey if you consume like maybe a little
bit less vitamin A than what we think
you should for months or years like
there like there are just physiological
changes to that take place to like
accommodate that and let you be fine and
not experience issues with like slightly
lower intake but not like complete
deficiency versus like in a depletion
repletion study who knows like it might
take weeks or months or years for those
adaptations to happen um that wouldn't
happen if you're just going through like
a two to four week period of just
consuming zero vitamin A um so yeah like
the um like translating depletion
repletion studies to the drri framework
is kind of like it is tacitly predicated
on the on the assumption that those
results would
generalize um but I think it's still an
open question like the extent to which
they actually do generalize so just like
purely on like a research design basis
there there are still some open
questions um and also as as mentioned
before like all of these considerations
are just for the nutrients where we
would consider there to be a lot of good
data MH to like determine e rdas ltis in
the first place as mentioned like plenty
of nutrients just have AIS which
inherently means that the research
informing those nutrient targets uh is
less plentiful or lower quality um and
as mentioned in the previous episode the
US and Europe don't always even agree
about which nutrients have enough data
to kind of support the drri or drv
framework versus just issuing AIS MH so
for instance like um in the US there are
uh like rdas and so by extension e as
well for vitamin E and magnesium in
Europe the efsa looked at the same body
of research and said ah no there's
there's not enough for that like we're
just going to issue AIS here um which
kind of like goes back
to uh discussion of like judgment calls
like there isn't just judgment calls
about analytical endpoints there's also
judgment calls about like the level and
quality of EV that exists to determine
which one of these Frameworks we're
pushing it into are we going the drri
route or are we going the AI route
um and uh another another just like well
recognized issue with this framework is
that it covers up and
conceals um a lot of messiness regarding
like nutrient sources and
bioavailability in the broader context
of an individual's diet cuz they are
like inherently and necessarily only
looking at like the intake of a single
nutrient as like a single variable um
but like you don't always uh like absorb
and utilize the same amount of a
nutrient that you might consume from
different sources so like a classic
example here is like uh heem bound
versus non-em Iron so like your your
body has like hemoglobin myoglobin
proteins with like little iron in them
and most of the iron you consume from
animal products is is heem iron um you
know now that I think about it that
might be a misnomer maybe it should be
myo iron because it's mostly coming from
myoglobin not hemoglobin but whatever
who cares um but yeah so like the the
oral bioavailability of that is higher
than most sources of non heem iron like
iron from plant sources that is either
just like um like mineral iron or just
like incorporated into other proteins
like your body does just generally
absorb and and utilize he bound iron uh
a little bit better um and and that's
also the case for like if if you've
looked into like mineral supplements
like uh differences in oral
bioavailability are probably something
you're well aware of like the classic
example is like mineral supplements that
are oxides versus chelates like there's
a huge difference in oral
bioavailability so if you just like go
to Walmart and look at the cheapest
calcium supplement you can buy you'll
see that it's probably calcium oxide I
would assume and the oral
bioavailability of calcium oxide is like
below 10% oh my gosh I think it's like
2% like it's it's basically a placebo
pill jeez um but like uh so people could
be taking that thinking they're getting
a certain amount of calcium and just
like nope sorry yeah and I'll um let's
see uh Lindsay could you could you just
make a note real quick for me to to
Google this um or just like search Pub
Med when we get done recording because I
I do want to verify like make sure I'm
not like cuz because I I know that oral
bioavailability for oxides is really low
but I I want to make sure I'm not like
totally underselling it and if I'm lying
to you right now there there will be a
note in the show notes okay hey just
making a really quick correction here in
post so with calcium in particular um
generally you you won't see calcium
oxide in supplements uh calcium
carbonate is the more common version
that you will see um and in general it
seems like chelated forms of calcium do
maybe have slightly better Oro
bioavailability than calcium carbonate
does but it is not nearly as big of a
difference um what I specifically had in
mind was stuff that I had read about
magnesium supplementation in particular
uh magnesium oxide does have horrible
oral bioavailability we're talking like
four or 5% um and that is generally true
of minerals where you will find oxide
forms and supplements uh but that does
not apply to calcium uh like I said uh
generally you'll see calcium carbonate
which again might not be quite as good
as chelated forms but is still uh pretty
good and does still have pretty decent
oral
bioavailability um sorry for that error
and now back to the
podcast um but like oral bioavailability
for oxides is in general considerably
lower than like chelated versions of the
same mineral right which is just like
the mineral bound to some other
biomolecule often times an amino acid so
um if you see like calcium or magnesium
like citrate or aspartate or whatever
like a word ending an eight eight um
that's a chelated ver or like um yeah it
doesn't like glycinate is is coming up
more more often these days in supplement
formulations doesn't matter like there
there are like little differences in
oral bioavailability between different
like keates of of various minerals but
usually it's just still like way way
better than oxides um and I the
differences between like different Keel
forms usually isn't big enough to worry
about uh for the most part but yeah like
if if memory serves I I think the oral
bioavailability for calcium oxide is
like 4% and for uh calcium citrate is
like 45% or something um like it's it's
a big difference yeah um so yeah like
none of that is communicated in dris
like if if all of the calcium you
consumed was from calcium oxide who
knows maybe the RDA for calcium would
need to be like 30 g a day or some
like that but you know for from dairy
products the oral bi availability is way
higher um and so like that's yeah that
is inherently not
communicated um and also like just other
things in the foods you consume as
mentioned before might positively
influence absorption of a nutrient so
like vitamin D helping with calcium
absorption but they can also sometimes
negatively influence absorption of a
nutrient so I think there's been maybe a
bit too much like scaremongering about
like so-called anti-nutrients
like Oates Andes and like I said think
people make them sound scarier they
actually are um but like the the fact
that they do interfere with mineral
absorption like is uncontroversially
true um and in particular calcium iron
magnesium and zinc so like you could you
could potentially argue that like foods
with oxalates and Fates are fine like
you can eat them but like if you eat a
diet that is rich in foods that are high
oxalates and Fates like maybe you should
try to consume a little bit more of some
of those minerals than people who ate a
diet lower and in those things and like
often times that goes hand inand like a
lot of the um like a lot of plants that
are relatively rich in oxalates are also
relatively mineral Rich so like it is a
little bit easier often times to consume
a little bit higher levels of minerals
if you are also eating like an oxat fate
Rich diet but uh all all of which is to
say once again like that's not
communicated in the drri framework yeah
um how could it be yeah yeah absolutely
not um and so yeah like basically all of
this stuff is like kind of messy and I
think yeah messier than I realized
before I started digging into it and
there's a lot of stuff that is not
communicated in the single number uh of
the RDA that most people are aware of
and pay attention to almost
exclusively um and so yeah like as we
talked about with the last episode when
things are communicated in a single
precise number I think that gives the
impression that the scientific consensus
is also like simple and precise like
that that is why it is Justified to just
give the single like precise
recommendation um but that's not the
case here yeah not at all however okay
however here's here's kind of the rug
pull for this segment um that's kind of
by Design and I think it's a good thing
okay um so it is it is a negative in
terms of if
people get if people see it and get
overconfident and and read into an RDA
like way more like nuance and precision
and and whatever than it actually has
and and like they know the rdas for uh
vitamins and minerals and assume that
that means they know a lot about those
things which relative to the general
population you do like most people
probably don't have those rdas like
memorized but like relative to how much
there is to know uh about all of this
stuff like you don't know anything if
that is all you're aware of and and
think that it is like a super like
precise single number that that applies
equally to everyone um but for most
people most of the time I actually think
it's good um and that is because dris
are supposed to primarily serve the
purpose of being Public Health
tools
and um especially as it regards to like
communicating with the public as
mentioned before like most people
there's no reason they would need to
know almost anything that I've talked
about in this episode like it wouldn't
serve them hardly any purpose um except
for like maybe a little piece of mind
like not like freaking out if they're
like a little bit below or a little bit
above the RDA but like I don't think
most people do freak themselves out
about that so like yeah Mo most of the
time like people just don't need to know
more information than that and typically
like I mean I know this firsthand as
someone who uh has made a career in the
long form content business like most
people don't want long form content like
it if it's if it's not something that's
like directly like important and
relevant to their lives um why spend two
hours like doing a deep dive on a topic
that a just a five minute little PSA
gives you enough for kind of moving
through the world in your day-to-day
life through the heart yeah and so if if
like all of the nuance and context for
every nutrient Target was communicated
for every nutrient Target for everyone
all the time yeah the net result
wouldn't be that people would end up
knowing more about micronutrients they
would end up knowing less because they
would look at it and say I don't
care yes and I'm not going to dig that
is way too much I yeah not doing this
and so what an RDA does by Design is
give you a single number where if
everyone hit that number
like around 98% of people would not be
not only not deficient any nutrient but
not even have insufficient intake of any
nutrient and that's a pretty powerful
thing to be able to communicate in a
single number and when you're trying to
communicate micronutrient intake needs
to a population 90 like in excess of 90%
of which
just like just don't care that much
right if you can if you can get that one
one thing through their head of like hey
if you if you reach this number you're
good um like that that's great for most
people most of the time um so yeah all
all of which is to say um I think that
for this podcast like if you're
listening to this you uh are way more
interested in and way more invested in
this stuff than most people are and you
like you you like knowing more you like
doing deep Dives uh and understanding
like context and nuance and all of that
um and so what we want to do with this
series is be able to provide that for
you because like rounding up and like
understanding all of this stuff for
myself was even more timec consuming
than the total runtime length of of this
podcast series you can imagine something
longer than this podcast yeah and and I
would at least like to think that this
is a communication medium that is more
pleasant and accessible than just like
asking you to dive into like all of the
EFS save reports for yourself 100% um
but it's also like yeah like way
overkill for almost everyone almost all
of the time and um but yeah if if if
you're interested enough in this topic
to be listening to this podcast it is I
think the amount that you should know
about this topic just to actually have
like a an actually good understanding of
it right yeah so don't let the messiness
stress you out correct um it was
starting to stress me out so I'm glad
that you said that yeah like I one of
one of my goals in life is just to make
people less overconfident about things
in general cuz I I think I think people
are just very overconfident about
that they have no no need to be yeah and
um so yeah my my general approach to
most things is I want to I want to knock
that over confidence down a Peg and then
communicate to people that yeah like
this is more complicated than you
thought it was but most things are fine
yeah you know um like often times it's
the net outcome is like you need to
stress about this thing less not more
because if if if like the the Baseline
Assumption of like this is like super
well supported and like crazy precise if
that was true then uh like a high level
of stress and anxiety about not meeting
nutrient rdas would be extremely
warranted but but since it is like kind
of a little Messier kind of a little
Loosey Goosey like yeah you a lot of
people can go like a little bit below
these most of the time you can go
considerably above and like nothing too
bad's going to happen either way um yeah
like it it communicates uncertainty but
also hopefully a sense of calmness and
peace of mind right I hope I think so
maybe not who knows um I I I think
people who have like a high
psychological need for closure
[Music]
um and and like just needing to I don't
think those people are here oh
absolutely not like I've I've I'm I
don't know where they are but they're
not here I assume I've weeded them out
over the years but anyway this might not
be good content for them but uh that's
fine that's that's not our target
audience okay um so let's move on kind
of the big picture thing that we want to
get across here is is that nutrient
guidelines are predicated on like cost
benefit analyses so it makes more sense
again like if you want to get into this
deeper instead of just looking at
rdas it makes more sense to think about
micronutrient intake guidelines as
ranges instead of exact targets so
instead of interpreting just the RDA as
like the thing that everyone needs to
hit all the time no matter what uh or
you know trying trying to be like sneaky
and say like ooh well well not sneaky
but but clever and say like ooh that's
actually two standard deviations above
actually the one number to pay attention
to is the E like that's the actual
average requirement let's just focus on
that one number instead of doing any of
that I think it just it just does make
more sense to think about it as ranges
yes where you you probably don't want to
be below the LTI like there's a pretty
there's a very good chance that you will
have sufficient intake if you're below
it or if you're someone whose actual
needs are closer to the RDA being below
the LTI might actually cause like a
deficiency not just an insufficiency so
like yeah you you probably do want to be
above the LTI and you some degree of
concern might be warranted if your
consumption of a particular nutrient is
regularly below the
LTI things with things in the lti2 RDA
range are generally like pretty okay um
where like if you're a little below the
E uh without without like extra medical
opinions or like blood work to like
confirm stuff like if you're a little
below the E like between the LTI and
E it probably wouldn't hurt to consume a
little bit more but like your risk of
nutrient deficiency is very low yeah and
as mentioned before like it's not great
to be insufficent
in like have insufficient intake of
particular nutrients but like usually
the actual kind of real world
consequences of that aren't particularly
serious MH so yeah like if you're if
you're between the LTI and E probably
wouldn't hurt to try to eat a little bit
more but you also I think probably
generally don't need to be that stressed
about it m if your intake is between the
E and RDA like you're you're doing good
like there's a very good chance you're
consuming sufficient amounts or if you
do just have like really high
intake needs for a particular nutrient
you'll only be like very slightly
insufficient in that range so like every
everyone's going to wind up with like
pretty decent outcomes there uh and then
between the RDA and the UL is is just
like is just good like you don't need to
you you don't need to be worried that
you're exceeding the RDA for something
and and worrying that that's going to
cause issues related to excessive intake
if you're below the UL because uls are
calibrated to be safe and conservative
um but also like you probably shouldn't
expect like additional great things to
happen if you're exceeding the RDA like
on purpose and and getting closer to the
UL like everything within that range
will probably have pretty similar
outcomes like just just good but you
know it's it's not going to do anything
like crazy or special and also not going
to be dangerous yep um and then above
the UL it's kind of a matter of like
degree and risk tolerance if you exceed
uls a little bit sometimes like you're
probably fine if you're regularly
exceeding them by a lot frequently for
prolonged periods of time might cause
problems um and yeah like I I think
that's just a good kind of like
range-based framework to think about
this
stuff
um all right so I believe that is about
it for the drri framework and nutrient
targets themselves and the last little
thing I have for this episode is uh
talking a little bit about micronutrient
tracking um and like micronutrient
contents of foods okay and um so yeah
let's let's get into it so
if you want to track your micronutrient
intake one of the things you should be
aware of is
that estimates of micronutrient intake
that you would generate from logging
your food and and trying to track your
your nutrient intake that way are
probably quite a bit more imprecise than
you
realize
um and so like I think I I think like
imprecision of nutrient intake tracking
is something a lot of people are aware
of if they spin a lot of time in like
nutrition world or Diet world like the
the little factoid like calorie counts
or like macronutrient counts of foods uh
by law can be up to 20% off like above
or below I think that's something that
there is General broad awareness of um
and so I don't think anyone is going
into it assuming that that they're
tracking is like uber prise like down to
a tenth of a percent or whatever um but
I I assume a lot of people don't
recognize that like micronutrient
tracking is considerably more imprecise
than macronutrient tracking um and that
errors can not only be larger in an
absolute sense but can also be like kind
of persistent for weeks or months at a
time so with macronutrients often times
and um I I wrote an article about this
for Stronger by science back in the day
that that will be linked in the show
notes but the the little fact toid that
is true that calorie counts and
micronutrient counts on food labels can
be off by up to 20% like ultimately like
that doesn't end up mattering too much
cuz like underestimates overestimates
like they'll tend to balance out um and
also like if
you um like especially with like energy
intake if if say you eat a diet where
just everything you you eat is kind of
under like the total calorie content is
like underestimated by 10% on food food
labels like it's kind of self-correcting
because the net result will just be that
you think your energy needs are like 10%
lower than they actually are and so um
yeah like you're you're actually uh
eating and expending more energy than
you believe you are but any sort of
adjustments you make have that tracking
error built in right kind of cancels out
like it it doesn't end up mattering
typically um but with micronutrients
things are a little bit hairier so you
are you do have like some degree of like
safety um related to like calorie and
and macronutrient labeling error because
like the
20% range is like feasible to enforce by
regulation um whereas for my
micronutrients generally people are just
reporting either like the the results of
like food fortification like hey we put
like 10 milligrams of iron per serving
back into this in which case like those
are probably very precise and accurate
numbers or in the case of like Whole
Foods um it it's just kind of like based
on like averages that are reported to
research databases and um there's no
there's no like force to like enforce
that cuz like you know if if you have
apples in a fruit cup and those apples
just have like lower levels of
carotenoids than most apples do and so
like you slightly overestimate the
vitamin A content of the apples and the
fruit cups like no one's going to come
after you for that because ultimately
it's not your job to like do a
full biochemical analysis of all of the
apples coming into your factory that go
into that food cup and so you're totally
safe and allowed to just assume that the
carotenoid content of those apples are
the same as every other Apple you know
um but like the the content of of
vitamins and minerals can differ
considerably between like different
fruits and vegetables to an extent that
I think folks are somewhat unaware of so
for instance and I'll I'll link this in
the show notes there was a 2018 study
testing the vitamin C content of of
various foods but like one of the they
looked at was baby spinach um and they
looked at the vitamin C content uh at
different points throughout the year and
they found that per 60 G serving of baby
spinach the level of vitamin C was
between 5.6 and
39.6 microgram or milligram of vitamin C
per serving MH which what is that that's
a Sevenfold range from the bottom to the
top so that's
quite a bit more than 20% above or below
kind of the median
value um and also unlike calorie or
micronutrient content where like
underestimates overestimates within the
context of a whole diet will generally
like average out in wash out um if
you're getting a lot of vitamin C from
eating baby spinach you would be um
alternately overestimating and
underestimating your vitamin C content
or your vitamin C intake for extended
periods of time because it wasn't just
like a random stochastic large range it
varied by season so during the winter uh
the vitamin C content averaged like 26
milligrams per 60 G serving and uh
during the summer it averaged like 10
Mig per 60 G serving so there was more
than a two-fold range not in terms of
like highest and lowest values but just
like average content during the summer
versus average content during the winter
um so yeah like you you could very
easily wind up with like relatively
large over underestimates for like weeks
or months at a time du due to that
seasonality component um and like I I
will also like readily admit that I
cherry-picked that like most
micronutrients don't have yeah it's an
extreme example as much variability or
as much like seasonality yeah like I I
chose an extreme example to to make a
point and I'm admitting that to you
don't get mad at me for cherry picking
cuz I admitted the cherry picking
spinach picking spinach picking yeah um
but like like I said just generally
trying to make that point that that um
things things aren't necessarily going
to wash out as much and the total amount
of variability can be quite a bit larger
um and like it's also going to depend a
little bit on like geography and farming
practice and just like what is the Dom
like cultivar of whatever whatever food
uh is like being planted in a particular
place in particular time um so like and
it also doesn't have to be like things
differing a ton if you're like half a
world away or in countries with like
drastically different regulations
related to um like soil fortification or
or um like irrigation or or fertilizer
or whatever so uh I'll also link this in
the show notes um there was a study
looking at like reported nutrient
content um for like various different
fruits and vegetables um in Germany and
the Netherlands which are like right
next to each other I assume they
probably have like pretty similar
regulations related to farming um and
they found that in general like a lot of
foods had like higher vitamin A and
vitamin C levels in Germany than the
Netherlands um
and like you know there could be like
slight differences in regulations or it
could just be a matter of like the um
like kind of Baseline levels of minerals
in the soil like influenced by the
characteristics of the underlying
bedrock um which yeah you're you're not
going to have like a good easy robust
way to account for that y um which kind
of like as supporting information for
this like why the the micronutrient
content of uh various foods can vary so
much is like it it makes sense when you
think about it and I think most people
just don't think about it and kind of
assume that plants are basically inert
it's just like a a biological container
for these nutrients that's like kind of
the same every time like they they grow
we pick it we eat it and like bada bing
bada boom it is what it is yep or uh if
you're like you
know if if you go go like maybe a step
deeper you might think that it's
influenced by like soil depletion a
little bit but yeah like as long as
you're using good farming practices
whatever like it it should basically all
be the same all the time but that's not
necessarily the case and like it I think
it's once I talk about this I think
you'll find the variability quite a bit
more intuitive okay so like with
vitamins mhm plants make vitamins MH we
eat the plants we get the
vitamins those vitamins serve purposes
for us
mhm they also serve purposes for the
plants makes sense and they don't always
serve the same purposes for plants that
they do for us and the needs of the
plants to produce vitamins depends on
what purpose they serve and how uh
whatever processes they're they're
supporting like vary over time so I'll
use vitamin C as an example here um
vitamin C for us as mentioned in the
last episode is a essential nutrient
because it's an important co-actor in
collagen synthesis like pretty pretty
easy simple enough plants uh I should I
should have looked this up before
hopping on the mic I don't think plants
produce collagen I think that's I mean I
know they don't have like tendons but um
I'm pretty sure they don't produce
collagen or if they do like they
certainly aren't producing much of it
like that's that's not the primary thing
vitamin C is doing in plans and and I I
don't think it's doing it at all anyway
it's primarily serves different purposes
in plants and vitamin c does a lot of
in Plants um so it has roles in
Iron uptake
photosynthesis hormone production so
like plants produce hormones as well uh
pathogen resistance all stages of the
cell cycle and quite a bit more um ah
man I looked up a review for this and
forgot to link it in the show notes or
uh uh in the outline I'll I'll find it
again to link it in the show notes but
yeah like vitamin C does a lot of stuff
in plants that is not the same stuff it
does for us and um like the needs
of like the the vitamin C needs of
plants are going to likely be
influenced um like by by where they are
in their growth cycle and like what
season they're in so for instance like
going back to spinach having more
vitamin C in the winter than the summer
like I I don't know this to be the case
but just like one possibility
is like vitamin C is important for
photosynthesis uh spinach is receiving
less direct sunlight in the winter than
the summer so like maybe it just needs
to make a little bit more vitamin C in
the winter to like help the process of
photosynthesis along so um but yeah like
all of these things like you know maybe
there's there's more pathogens like in
the winter than the summer so it needs
higher vitamin C production to like help
with pathogen resistance but yeah
essentially like it is serving an
important purpose for the plant and the
plants needs for it aren't going to be
exactly the same all the time so like
the production isn't going to be the
same all the time so like the amount can
vary over time um and in the case of
minerals so so that's with vitamins like
they serve purposes in plants and the
needs of the plants for those vitamins
can vary over time yeah the plants need
vitamins too yes they can use them for
minerals it is like mostly dependent on
soil conditions like most most of the
minerals that wind up in plants get
there because there's minerals in the
soil they're taken up in the roots and
then transported elsewhere in the plant
and so the mineral content of plants is
going to be heavily influenced by soil
conditions um so I mention like soil
depletion before like that's that's
something that there's been I think like
a bit of a moral Panic about and I I
think people are also like slightly too
freaked out about where it's like ah
like there's less like magnesium and
pepper than there was when our
grandfathers were our age or whatever
like that that that actually is true to
some extent um but the the extent of the
decrease doesn't therefore imply that
like the fruits and vegetables we
consume are like un nutritious like they
but they are like maybe a little bit
less micronutrient-dense than they used
to be um largely again due to soil
depletion like there's a lot of people
eating a lot of food um and like once
magnesium from the soil is taken up into
a plant and shipped off to Market and
consumed like that particular magnesium
molecule is not in the soil anymore so
if it's not repleted over time like with
with uh like mineral enhanced
fertilizers or whatever or just like um
in some farming practices there there
are just like mineral supplements that
you would like put in the soil to like
replete it um just imagine burying
little pills your vitamins I mean I I
think it's powdered or or like disol in
water uh but yeah like so that is ALS
like that's going to influence the
mineral content of foods and so yeah
like um a food grown in like a more
mineral rich soil will just have like
typically higher mineral content than
the same food grown in more mineral por
soil um and it it could be a pretty
significant difference between those two
pieces of produce which again just like
like an average number from like a
standard research database isn't
necessarily going to capture that y um
just as a general aside
the wildest example of this that I came
across was probably
selenium
um and and so like the same general
process applies with other minerals but
like selenium seems to be one of the
minerals with like the most extreme
differences between like selenium rich
and selenium poor soils um and uh yeah
so like overall selenium intake
basically seems to be like a crapshoot
where like it's so heavily influenced by
soil conditions and it can vary so much
which like that that relates just to
like Bedrock stuff like there's just
more selenium rich and selenium poor
bedrock and that kind of percolates up
into the soil yeah and so um yeah like
there there are foods that are like
generally selenium rich or like have
selenium but like if it's grown in like
super selenium poor soil like you might
still wind up consuming almost none um
and so like that's been observed in uh
parts of the US and parts of Europe um
like those Regional differences are
observed it's also been observed in
China and like China seems to be the
area of the world with like the most
extreme differences from like the most
selenium Rich to selenium poor regions
so there are two diseases linked to
selenium deficiency that are I believe
only uh observed in like different parts
like like selenium Poe parts of China
that like haven't been observed outside
of that cuz like in the grand scheme of
things like like true selenium
deficiency is like quite rare um but
like it has been noted in China so
there's a disease called keson disease k
s h- an which is like a particular type
of cardi myopathy that has only been
observed in like these almost completely
selenium deficient regions of China
never heard of that before another one
called cashen Beck disease which is also
again like a very particular type of
osteoarthritis that is only observed in
those like completely selenium deficient
regions um and then also there there
were issues in China in the 80s with
like selenium toxicity in this one
region which was like the result of coal
runoff that was apparently like very
selenium Rich that got into the soil um
and like the people generally seem to be
fine and then like their hair and like
fingernails started falling out which is
which is like the first like obvious uh
uh outcome of like uh selenosis like Hy
like excess selenium intake um but yeah
yeah so just as kind of a a bit of a
case study in how soil levels of a
particular nutrient can influence um
intake of that nutrient cuz like the
dietary patterns of the people getting
like Keshon or cashen Beck disease
weren't like dramatically different than
people who weren't getting those
diseases it's just like other people
were like farming and growing rice and
more selenium Rich regions and though
those were like super selenium poor
regions so like eat broadly the same
stuff and most of the folks in China
were eating enough selenium and folks in
those particular regions were eating
almost none um and also like I I
mentioned in the last episode that
selenium I found it fascinating when I
was looking at research on micronutrient
so this is just like a little bit of an
aside um but it has like the craziest
dose response curve in terms of like
outcomes of High versus low selenium
intake and like the broad number of
things that are influenced by selenium
intake and and so like for like I didn't
know anything about selenium until I
started looking into micronutrient
research um like it's it's just not a
nutrient like people think about hardly
ever um unless they really love Brazil
nuts which are like super selenium rich
and so like you can maybe wind up with
like excess selenium consumption if you
eat like a shitload of Brazil nuts
anyway beyond that like most people have
no reason to ever think about selenium
um when I hear it it sounds like the
name for the Stan Army of Selena
Gomez uh I can see that those are the
selenators though so a little different
interesting I did not know that uh but
yeah so um selenium is an essential
nutrient because it is incorporated into
proteins called seleno proteins which do
do a bunch of stuff uh but the in in
general like most nutrients it's thought
that like the general effects of
selenium on human health have like a
U-shaped curve where like if you don't
consume enough bad stuff happens if you
consume too much bad stuff happens and
then there's just kind of like an
optimal intake in the middle but for
specific things that are influenced by
selenium intake you see like wildly
different dose response curves so like
with selenium intake and type two
diabetes risk there's like almost just a
linear relationship where higher
selenium intakes are associated with
like linearly higher rates of type to
diabetes um but for cancer risk uh like
like celeno proteins are involved in
like various aspects of like immunity
and cell cycle regulation and whatnot um
for certain cancers there's just like a
negative linear relationship between
selenium intake and and uh incidence of
those cancers but then like it it's for
other cancers there are just like
different dose response curves and like
it's it's crazy like I found it I found
it fascinating both uh how much like
soil levels and therefore like intake
levels differ and like how much just
geography influences solidium intake and
then also the fact that like I had it in
my mind that for like most nutrients
there there was just kind of that like
inverted u-shaped relationship where
like there is an amount that's good you
go above that it if you go too far above
that it's bad if you go too far below it
it's bad but with with selenium like the
the if you conceive of like General
Health as a broad category you see that
same like inverted you shaped
relationship but for like specific
outcomes you're seeing just like weird
linear relationships going different
ways for different outcomes like oh my
gosh it's wild man um anyway I just
thought that was neat and so I wanted to
share it it's a bit of a wild card yeah
um so yeah talked a little bit about PL
like why why nutrient concentrations
differ either the the needs of the plant
to produce that nutrient vary over time
or by region for for various reasons
because those vitamins are serving like
functional purposes for the plants uh
and for minerals levels can vary mostly
due to soil conditions for animals like
animal products the um primary Dynamic
to keep in mind is the uh concept of
bioaccumulation which is just that like
for certain vitamins and minerals they
just accumulate up the food chain so
they're initially produced by a plant or
like a plankton or something and they're
eaten by small herbivores which are
eaten by small Predators which are eaten
by large larger predators and it just
just percolates up the food chain like
that yep um so a good example of this is
like omega-3 concentrations in Salmon
are like close to three times higher in
wild salmon than farmed salmon what um
yeah cuz like farmed salmon are just
kind of fed feed I guess like that makes
sense I didn't know that though like I
know the bad example of like mercury and
fish but I didn't know omega-3 and
salmon being so much higher in in wild
salmon yeah yeah that's really
interesting yeah that is um that's
another thing where I think
folks I think there there might be like
a little bit too much scar mongering
over like farmed versus fresh like uh
Seafood products or whatever but I mean
in the case of Omega-3 content and
salmon like it it is it is true that
like fresh does considerably better damn
um and the reason for that is that most
of the omega3 in the Marini ecosystem is
made by phyto Plankton MH which are then
consumed by Little Fishies consumed by
bigger fishies and some of those bigger
fishies are salmon and so like wild
salmon are consuming Omega-3s that that
have kind of concentrated up the food
chain by the time it got to them yep
like Plankton have a little Omega-3s the
Little Fishies that eat the Plankton get
the Omega-3s from the Plankton so they
have a little bit higher levels the
slightly larger fishies that eat those
get the Omega-3s from the very little
fishies and then salmon eat those
slightly larger fishies and so yeah like
efficient it bio accumulation um the
example of mercury you gave like like
you said that's that is the exact same
principle but kind of negative and in
Reverse where yeah like there's like
very low levels of mercury in water but
like it gets into the Plankton or like
the very little fishies and then as
larger and larger fish eat those smaller
fish they just get higher and higher
mercury levels cuz at no point along the
way can any of them EX re the Mercury
and so it just bioaccumulates up the
food
chain uh and um one interesting thing to
note about that is like that wasn't
something people needed to worry about
until the mid 1800s because like almost
all of the Mercury and water came from
burning coal and so like I guess there
were there there was probably like
technically slightly higher levels of
mercury in like tuna than like Shad in
1820 or whatever but there were still
really low levels of mercury and tuna in
1820 but then once Cal burning power
plant started popping up all over the
place it just like raised kind of the
background level of mercury and water
high enough that you could get enough
bio accumulation to potentially be
dangerous if you eat too much predatory
fish too often uh which is a bummer but
yeah that's that's where it came from
yeah it's not just like an inherent
facet of the world it's
something we up it's the result
of the first Industrial Revolution and
things that have followed it uh another
example is like vitamin A um so this was
this was something that uh on the first
episode people were just like ah why
didn't you mention this one fun fact I
know about a particular nutrient
um that probably sounded too dismissive
but no like I I okay okay little it's
just such a specific piece of feedback
that it seems like like a lot of people
gave like close to a dozen people did I
I got I got a lot of DMS about this one
specific thing is it about be bear liver
yeah it's about be liver it is a fun
fact I almost said it earlier I mean
that would be fine it's no so okay okay
this is this is a little aside and this
is just going to be me complaining for a
brief second one of the things that gets
under my skin Oh My God one of the
things that gets under my skin uh is
when I'm
given feedback or
criticism that implies that I am
uninformed or don't know something
simply because I did not mention that
one thing in one single piece of content
yes um that makes sense and oh my God
and and if it's just like one thing in
one episode of the podcast it's cool but
when over the course of two weeks I get
like a dozen people being like oh did
you not know about like bar liver and
vitamin A I'm like shut shut the up
all of you like it it uh it it irks me
after a while cuz it's like no guess
what the episodes are already long do
you want me to tell you everything I
know about nutrition every time we do a
nutrition episode on the podcast no
because each episode would be slightly
longer than they currently are and no
one wants that um anyway yeah vitamin A
bio accumulates up the food chain uh and
here here here's a fun little fact for
for you folks that know the fact about
bear liver aggressive so um you you have
probably heard that yeah if you like a
single bite of polar bear liver has
enough vitamin A to kill someone like if
if you eat like pretty much any polar
bear liver there's there's a very good
chance you're going to die um stay away
from polar bears and their organs and
everything polar bears are spooky man
they are they hunt humans we're in their
food chain don't with them don't
with them um anyway yes they have
toxic levels of vitamin A in their liver
um but it is also generaliza true that
other Predators also have high levels of
vitamin A in their liver like y higher
than the herbivores that they might be
eating because of the same process of
bioaccumulation but polar bears in
Arctic animals in particular are
kind of the only ones to which the the
principle of like a single bite will
kill you applies like if you had like a
single bite of black bear liver like it
probably wouldn't taste good and it it
if you had like a large serving it might
have enough vitamin A to to you up
but it also has like way lower vitamin A
concentrations than polar bear livers do
like um and so it's but also that same
concern relates to other Arctic animal
so it's not exclusive to polar bears
like bearded seals also have like
similarly high levels of vitamin A and
so if you ate bearded seal liver it
would also kill you um and that is
because like due to the the principle of
bioaccumulation um like it's a thing
that's fairly specific to the Arctic
just because the bottom level of that
food chain just has like particularly
high like vitamin A Levels like the the
Arctic Plankton that are at the very
base of that food chain that start that
process of
bioaccumulation just have higher vitamin
A Levels than like grass does that you
know like would be the base of a
terrestrial food system um but yeah yeah
so so for people listening I knew that
fun fact and in fact I knew another fun
fact about that fun fact Greg you know
so many fun facts everyone knows that
it's all right I know I'm I probably get
too worked up about that but it it is it
is just like like the the if someone
says hey I wish you would have mentioned
this thing that's cool mhm if it's how
how do how did you not know this like
were you why are you unaware of this
thing it's like don't don't make that
assumption like it it bothers me I'm a
person too I have
feelings okay uh let's let's move on
okay um because we're we're just about
done okay so uh yeah micronutrient
content varies considerably there's more
variability than there is uh than like
labeling error in calories and and
macronutrients for like very
understandable reasons in animal
products like different amounts of stuff
like like different amounts of nutrients
lower in the food chain allow for
different levels and amounts of Bio
accumulation up a food chain and just
like the age of the animal is going to
matter as well like how long has it had
to consume stuff and for it to bio
accumulate in that animal itself uh for
plants again and vitamins serve purposes
in Plants the the need their needs for
the vitamins differ over time so their
production of the vitamins differs over
time minerals a lot of it's about soil
conditions um so yeah there there is
just a lot of variability there both
over time between different regions etc
etc you get the point um so that is just
something to be aware of if you are
interested in tracking micronutrient
intake with calories macros you can be
like reasonably confident that the
number at the end of the day is probably
within about 5 or 10% of your actual
intake as long as you did a pretty good
job of logging with
micronutrients you should like in your
head just build in a little bit more
fuzz when you're looking at that number
like if um yeah if you see you had I
don't know 700 milligrams of vitamin A
or micrograms whatever whatever the
units are doesn't matter um well it
matters a lot
but uh we'll just go with milligrams if
you see that you consumed 700 milligram
of uh vitamin A today um just kind of
like build in maybe like
20% 20 30% range of like fuzziness
around that like you know maybe it says
700 maybe your actual consumption was
500 550 maybe it was like 900 1,000 like
it is but it should be it should at
least point you in the right direction
but the the amount of precision you can
track with is inherently lower than it
is for calories or
macros um and then just the final thing
to note about this is that
micronutrients are a little bit
difficult to track if you would just
like to track micronutrients to to
understand how much you're consuming now
and just kind of like AIT intake for
yourself so um government agencies and
and regulations don't require
manufacturers to list all of the
nutrients contained in the food on a
food label yeah um and they're not
required to like have a secondary
database or whatever that they then
report to the government of like hey you
know I might only list nine nutrients on
the label but we we actually have this
data on all of these other nutrients
behind the scenes like they're not
required to have that at all and they
don't um so and like
the the fact that it's not all listed on
nutrition labels makes a lot of sense
cuz like it would be very big yeah if
every essential nutrient was listed on
every nutrition label the sheer size of
the list would take Focus away from like
higher priority nutrients that
governments like do want people to
actually pay attention to for public
health reasons um and so yeah in in most
countries like food manufacturers are
only required to report energy content
macronutrient content sugar saturated
fat fiber uh and depending on the
country either salt or sodium um and
that's that's it as far as things that
are fairly
Universal um and a lot of countries then
also have regulations regarding like
food fortification like if you do add
some like iron or B vitamins to the food
or whatever like the synthetic vitamins
or minerals that you add to the food
like your ired to report them on the
label as well um but beyond that like
there are some like country specific
things so like in the US Food
manufacturers have to report iron
calcium vitamin D and potassium like
food manufacturers in Europe for
instance don't have to report those
things but yeah there's there's a fairly
small list of mandatory reporting
requirements for nutrients everything
beyond that is voluntary and if it's
voluntary they ain't doing it yeah
they're absolutely not so um in the
article on the macro Factor website I
I'll link to this in the show notes
there was a study um looking at the uh
uh frequency of nutrient reporting on UK
Food level or UK food labels like what
percentage of food labels reported about
this nutrient and there's just like a
long list and I'm just going to ask
listeners to like look at that list and
try to try to figure out for themselves
what nutrients are mandatory on UK
nutrition labels and which are voluntary
yeah and I'll just tell you it's
obvious like the the reporting
frequency goes from like in excess of
95% down to like I think like 70
something per for fiber which is
voluntary but like it's a voluntary one
that a lot of people did choose to
report down to I think the next one was
maybe calcium at like 8% of food labels
like single digits just falls off a clip
so if something is not a mandatory
reporting nutrient like just no one
reports it um
so if you do want to track your
micronutrients you're going to need some
way to reference like uh like government
or research databases that will have
like robust micronutrient intake for
Foods the the analog way to do this is
just keep a food journal uh write down
on everything you consume in a day try
to make note of like portion sizes and
then just like pull up the USDA database
and look at each food for yourself and
make note of things like I I'm making
the point that like yes we sell a
nutrition app and you can do this much
easier and quicker in the app but you
absolutely do not have to use it or any
other nutrition application to do it
like it it is possible to do it kind of
manually of course um sounds not fun
though yeah but it's it it is much I
don't just say this because I'm an
interested party it is just like
objectively much faster and easier to do
it using an app that allows you to do it
um and you're going to need an app that
uh is like hooked up to highquality
research grade databases that have
plenty of foods with robust
micronutrient reporting and even then
like it is still more of a hassle than
just tracking macros and calories
because like I said most branded food
products do not have micronutrient
information um so you would need to
track like common food equivalents for
instance like you know if you had a if
you had like a Whopper from BK you
couldn't just track a Whopper and get
the micronutrients for it like you would
need to um try to find like a beef entry
uh it doesn't have cheese does it no
Whoppers don't have cheese but like a a
beef entry a bun entry like ketchup
pickles whatever um that pretty closely
match the macronutrient and energy
content of the Whopper and will give you
a pretty good approximation of therefore
the micronutrient content of said
sandwich um so yeah like you'll you'll
need to track your food and use like
common food equivalents from research
grade databases instead of just being
able to like scan barcodes and pretty
easily log branded Foods right so it
does it does take more effort even if
you use an app that allows you to do it
and save a lot of effort over the manual
approach like it yeah it is just still a
little bit more difficult yes especially
if you eat a lot of branded Foods yes if
you don't eat a lot of branded Foods
it's about the same amount of time yeah
um so yeah just to wrap up this episode
cuz we we have reached the end of the
content I had prepared okay um takeaways
one there are still a surprising number
of open questions related to
macronutrients um as discussed in the
last episode we're still not even like
100% sure we have a comprehensive list
of all essential and conditionally
essential nutrients and as discussed in
this episode the research describing
intake needs for essential nutrients is
still in a lot of cases surprisingly
sparse um for example there are still a
lot of nutrients that just have AIS
instead of like being able to work in
the in the drri framework um and there
are still like some methodological
concerns and just like analytical
concerns related to to the data that
does exist so um yeah this is we we know
a lot more than we did a 100 years ago
but there's still a lot of open
questions a lot more to learn and a lot
of room for just more research and and
methodologic Al better research in in a
lot of cases number two um with the
first thing being said there is an
element of just like the proof being in
the pudding um like we we probably do
understand micronutrient needs not as
well as we could but probably good
enough yeah and the food supply in
modern industrialized countries is like
broadly sufficient for most people to be
fine without ever thinking about
micronutrient intake um as as you
mentioned at the start lenss going
through the history we used to see a lot
of disease that was like specifically
linked and owing to micronutrient
deficiencies in 2023 like we we just
don't um at least in wealthy countries
where people have access to enough food
and food from diverse food sources um in
like really imp aish communities that
have like less access to food less
access to like diverse food choices like
there there are still issues but like
like by and large it it was an access
question and for most people the access
question has been solved and so like
most of the time like people people are
fine and they don't need to be that
concerned about micronutrient intake um
and so yeah if you're not generally
undernourished and you regularly consume
foods and beverages from all major food
groups you're you're probably going to
be okay um and yeah I I don't think that
this is something that most people need
to be preoccupied with or overly
concerned about unless you have specific
symptoms that uh could be like directly
attributable to a to a micronutrient
deficiency and you go to your doctor
they get blood work and they say like
hey yeah like you have say like anemia
cuz your iron super low like maybe try
to consume more iron like that that
still happens but that th those are
things that can be addressed in a
medical context and yeah if you have
concerns related to that talk to your
doctor but again like most people most
of the time are are broadly fine um
though I will note there are some
exceptions so the first one is there are
like certain diseases conditions or
medications that can increase your
micronutrient needs um but if you have
any of those things you're doctor will
probably tell you about it and say like
hey supplement with this thing you'll be
fine uh two is that people with diets
that involve excluding entire food
groups might need to be a little bit
more concerned so makes sense all of
this is in the context of consuming
sufficient food from broadly diverse
sources yeah if you yeah just exclude
entire food groups from your diet like
there is a greater likelihood that you
might have issues related to
insufficient micronutrient intake um and
then this is the only like really
specific like kind of recommendation
that I'll give related to this stuff um
is that if you're listening to this and
you're um a a a darker skinned person
like if you're African-American Hispanic
uh like South Asian or whatever living
in the US or northern Europe um there's
a there's a decent chance that it might
not be a bad idea to get checked for uh
like vitamin D status so um I I'll link
a paper related to this in the show
notes uh like I mentioned in the last
episode um your the the ability of the
skin to synthesize vitamin D differs by
latitude because that influences like
how direct the sunlight is and how many
UV rays are are reaching your skin um
and like melanin content of the skin
skin also affects that like it protects
you from sunburn like fewer UV rays
penetrate the skin but fewer are
penetrating the skin also to stimulate
vitamin D
synthesis um so yeah like the rates of
like like very low vitamin D levels in
the blood are like 15 to 20 times higher
in uh people living in America of
African descent versus European descent
so um yeah like that's that that is a
pretty broad difference and so yeah if
you're like black or brown listening to
this you live in the US or Europe and
you haven't had your vitamin D levels
checked it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea to do so yeah um and then last
thing is uh if you'd like to audit your
micronutrient intake you'll generally
need to do some food logging since most
micronutrients aren't listed on food
labels um if you do that again you can
do it manually it's going to take you
forever um you'll you'll probably want
to use an app that does have like common
foods coming from research databases um
that are integrated and obviously
labeled for you to choose those to be
the ones you track um and yeah macro
Factor does this you should check it out
it's great um but it's not the only one
that does so uh so yeah there there are
other options out there just want to
make that clear um but uh specific
benefit of macro factor is I believe we
are the only app that does actually
clearly list the ranges of nutrients
like showing you the LTI RDA and UL for
for various nutrients instead of just
presenting everything as just like one
target or maybe like the RDA and the UL
so anyway I think it's a great product
um but I don't I don't want to make it
sound as if it is necessary to track
your your micronutrient intake there
there are other
options
um so yeah that's that's about it as far
as content goes but I do have just two
little things related to this to end on
one is depressing and the other is kind
of cool okay can I lead with the
depressing one so that we don't end on a
low note yes okay
so um as I just mentioned if you live in
a develop country and have access to
plenty of food and diverse food
choices you generally don't need to
worry about micronutrient intake all
that much like you're you're probably
going to be fine or if you're consuming
like a little bit less of a nutrient
than you need to it'll probably be in
kind of that insufficient range rather
than the deficient range and often times
like insufficiencies like aren't that
bad aren't that scary so like H whatever
most of the time it's fine but that is
not Universal worldwide um like in
lower and even some middle inome
countries uh diseases like related to or
directly the result of micronutrient
deficiencies are still very common and I
think I think a lot of people don't
fully understand like how common um like
like deaths due to starvation and
undernutrition and not even just deaths
but just like crit iCal lifelong health
problems like related to to
undernutrition are still around the
world like so still like in 2023 around
like 9 to 10 million people per year die
um from
malnutrition and some of that is due to
like kind of starvation per se like just
less energy than than one would need to
survive but a lot is due to like
under nutrition from like micronutrients
so you know like like peligra and like
berry berry they're they're not really
things in America anymore but like they
are still things in like other parts of
the world um and so like yeah severe
micronutrient deficiencies are still
like a really major Global Health
concern um again like on a scale that I
think a lot of people don't realize like
9 to 10 mil people a year like that's
that's a lot um like what's the quote
like one death is a tragedy but a
thousand is a statistic like I I think
that still so many people are
dying of malnutrition that it it is if
if you hear this it can be easy for it
to um yeah just come across as a
statistic instead of like mass human
tragedy on an almost unimagined scale
but it is mass tragedy on an
unimaginable scale and
um yeah I don't know like ah not to not
to be like too fatalistic about this but
like it's it it is a problem that is
like
solvable to a degree that makes me like
extremely mad MH cuz like it's it's not
something that like I can do anything
about in a tangible way or any of you
listening could do anything about it in
a tangible way but like there like the I
I think the
estimated the estimated cost like
globally for just like completely
eradicating severe malnutrition um and
again like saving 9 to 10 million lives
per year which again like that's a
shitload of people the the last I saw
like the estimated cost to like make
that not a thing anymore it's like 40
billion a year which like that's a
that's a big number I don't have $40
billion but that's like for instance
like just to pull a a random comparison
out of the hat like that's like 12th of
the United States military budget yep um
so yeah like that's that's cool
and it pisses me off every time I think
about it um but if you uh if you would
like to like at least try to make a
small difference uh in that area there
there there are a lot of like
highquality Charities that that um like
help with food fortification and like
food access in parts of the developing
world where severe malnutrition is still
common um one that I'll that I'll link
in the show notes that you might want to
check out uh is called gain which stands
for Global Alliance for improved
nutrition um like I said there there are
plenty of others like another another
good one is like iodine Global Network
which um helps with like uh like salt
iodization programs which like we don't
think that much about like goers anymore
in the US but like that used to be a big
thing cuz like people were iodine
deficient and severe iodine deficiencies
during early childhood um is related to
like well well not related to
causes um like impeded uh like mental
development um which is like not
rectifiable like it's a lifelong thing
so there there are like other Charities
like that that kind of Target
specific micronutrients where where
malnutrition is common uh but gain is
like a highly rated like well-run
charity that kind of takes a holistic
approach to helping out with some of
these
problems um and so yeah like if if the
if that's something that uh you care
deeply about um that that would be a
good place to to send some money
um so that's the that's the depressing
one shift gears ah it's it's going to be
hard to end on a high note after this
but um other just little thing okay
related so this is this is one of I
think the funner funner facts uh related
to
micronutrients God I'm trying to put
myself in a better head space because I
don't this this okay okay I've got it I
can do it um so
micronutrients and in particular vitamin
D likely played a pretty large role in
the success of the Vikings um which is
just I think a fun little historical
fact so in the last episode we talked
about vitamin D deficiencies and rickets
and Osteo malatia and how that causes
like poor bone formation people wind up
short um and yeah so that was like a big
thing in a lot of Europe during the time
that the Vikings were were crushing it
and doing their thing um and if you if
you go back and read like contemporary
accounts of Viking raids people talk
like these are absolute giants like
raiding our village like what is going
on here yeah um but like they weren't uh
so the the thing is like people from
like Norway Sweden like the the parts of
the world where the Vikings came from
they were like about the same height
during the era of the Viking raids as
they are now like they just didn't have
the same growth stunting that the rest
of Europe was dealing with and that may
seem somewhat counterintuitive cuz
really high latitude much less direct
like uh sunlight for vitamin D synthesis
but um they ate a lot of fish and they
kind of took the don't let anything go
to waste approach to eating fish F and
so they consumed uh a lot of cod liver
and cod liver oil and cod liver oil is
is quite rich in vitamin D and so
um like probably the largest reason that
they were just like so much larger and
more physically imposing than anyone
else in Europe who they were Waging War
against was just because like they were
consuming enough vitamin D yeah um and
that's why to think about because like
that has had pretty major
ramifications in just like world history
so like a a little one is um the English
language is kind of a descendant of
Germanic and romance languages but is
also I don't know if it's totally unique
but it's fairly unique in that we don't
have like gendered nouns besides nouns
for like people or animals that are
clearly of AG gender but like you know
we like a table for instance it's it's
just the table it's not like Mr or Miss
for instance yeah um whereas like most
Germanic and romance languages do have
that and I don't think the exclusive
reason but like one of the the reasons
that that is not the case in English is
because of the Vikings like after they
they raided the British Isles like a lot
of them also settled in the British
Isles um they took they took British
wives and they tried to learn the
language and uh like like Old English
did have gendered nouns but like the
Vikings learned the language pretty well
but like they just didn't want to deal
with that so like they just dropped
it yeah and I am very grateful for that
cuz like when I was trying to learn
German in school like I did not like
learning like what is it like Dar Tish
for table or like def fster for window
whatever like I don't I don't remember
like most of them and like I I feel like
that's unimportant like it's a table
it's not Mr table like it's fine um so
that's like a little thing another thing
is like as a somewhat indirect result of
the success of the Viking raids uh at
least partially owing to their their uh
consumption of cod liver o oil and
vitamin D is um the progression of
feudalism and like the crystallization
or or like the start of the process of
like State formation in Europe where
basically like since the fall of the
Roman Empire with the exception of just
like a brief period during the
carolingian Renaissance and like
Charlamagne his sons whatever um there
weren't really like States in Europe
like there were just little
principalities and like yeah little
hamlets and whatnot and there there
weren't like what we would would think
of as nation states um and there also
certainly weren't what we would think of
as like modern Nations by the end of the
period of Viking raids but like there
were there was like a bit of feudal
order at the start of of the Viking
related period um and one of the issues
that people had was like individual like
Coastal Lords couldn't like Marshall
enough forces to uh like successfully
repel Viking raids so it led to like the
need for more cooperation and like
centralization of authority to be able
to like start being able to more
efficiently coordinate responses to
Viking raids and like that was one of
the first steps down the path to like
the development of what we think of now
as like European nation states um and
like if the Vikings weren't eating the
vitamin D and they were smaller and
punier and couldn't rate US successfully
um yeah who who who knows who knows what
Europe and uh by extension cuz like
Europe for better or worse I think in a
lot of cases for worse uh played played
a pretty large role in shaping uh world
history starting like a couple years
after that with um yeah you know
exploration and uh the slave trade and
colonization and all of that so who
knows if if or how or when like any of
that would have happened or not for the
Vikings consuming vitamin D and like
like I'm not I'm not trying to create
like a grand theory of History where
that was just like the one causal Factor
but you know the the the the way that
just like a small thing can like at
least have like a partial influence on
ultimately like large cascading effects
subsequent like I just think it's kind
of neat to think about but at the end of
the day the Vikings not all that big and
scary by modern standards but by the
standards of their day big and scary
because of the vitamin D cool thing to
end on
um that's all I got yeah what are we
going to talk about next episode uh
we're going to talk more about
micronutrients it will be the third part
and final part in the series um where
we'll talk a little bit more
about like if you do want to uh like
track and monitor your micronutrient
intake like which which ones might you
want to pay a little bit closer
attention to cuz like the the risk of
like insufficient intake or like rates
of insufficient intake do differ like
pretty dramatically where some things
like basically no one's consuming
insufficient amounts like sodium for
instance unless you're trying to consume
a low sodium diet like you're you're
probably fine like you're consuming
enough maybe too much who knows um but
then like for other nutrients like
deficiency are rare but like
insufficient intake eating a little bit
less than like maybe you you could or
should is considerably more common like
we'll we'll talk about that a little bit
um and we'll talk a little bit about why
you should if you pay attention to
micronutrients you shouldn't be
like too tunnel visioned about it and
think about them excessively kind of
outside of the context of like the
overall food Matrix and just like other
beneficial things about food that aren't
just purely down to like quantifiable
micronutrient intake um and also I I
want a chance to take questions um cuz
I'm sure by the end of the series people
probably have some questions about
micronutrients and so uh I think those
first two things I mentioned I don't
think they'll take that long to get
through hopefully we'll see I mean we
thought this would be a shorter episode
um but I I would like to have time to
answer listener questions so that's
that's probably what we have on deck for
next time sounds good cool all right uh
thanks for listening uh as mentioned at
the top of the show we will be back to
chat with you more in three weeks
instead of two uh hope they go great
thanks for listening and goodbye
bye